so apparently Kanye West shows up to the
Skechers offices in Los Angeles
unannounced and then was escorted out of
the building so we don't know exactly
why but uh this story is apparently
breaking and it just comes amid the fall
of Kanye West and and the fall of his
Empire he's no longer a billionaire he's
been dropped by a ton of different
companies and so uh with this news just
coming out I think it's interesting
considering his support for Trump his
politics what's happening with the Lex
Friedman interview so we're going to
talk a bit about what's going on with
Kanye West but we do have a lot of other
news the the headline the title of this
podcast changed a bit because we're
hearing also that PayPal reinstated
their fine of twenty five hundred
dollars they didn't reinstate it it's
it's always been there or at least
except for several years what they took
out was the misinformation what's still
there is they can find you for hate
speech
so I think most people just didn't
realize that provision's been in there
for a very long time at least two or
almost three years now so we'll talk
about that plus Elon Musk he walks into
Twitter HQ with the kitchen sink so good
for him he's going to be buying the
platform everybody's really excited and
of course we got to talk politics
because it's getting crazy out there man
Real Clear Politics says that the
Republicans are going to win 53 seats
in the Senate that's crazy and now
they're saying that Michigan is going to
go Republican yeah this is getting nuts
Democrats are about to get a major
blowout loss so let's talk about that
stuff before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com and become a
member in order to support our work as a
member you'll get access to our
exclusive members only show Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM check it out
on the website plus the cast Castle Vlog
you'll also be supporting us and uh
we've got a contest coming up soon I'm
really excited I think we're filming it
this weekend and as a member you're
supporting our journalists elad aliyahu
was on the ground in New York he
actually got to talk to Carolyn Maloney
about her support for governor hokel in
uh in her reelection bid so there's
really interesting stuff there so again
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this share with your
friends be the notification you want to
see in this world because YouTube is not
notifying people YouTube has us somewhat
suppressed but if you guys take the URL
to this YouTube video or this podcast or
whatever and just share it everywhere
the censorship is meaningless joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is you Ian Pryor thanks for
having me who are you who am I Ah that's
a good question uh well I I'm live in
Loudoun County Virginia which is kind of
the epicenter of all all fun things
especially related to the school system
but you know it's probably Ground Zero
in in what happened in in Virginia in
2021 with with Glenn yunkin getting
elected and being the first Republican
governor in you know 12 years uh you
know I joined a lot of parents last year
that was pushing back on on the school
system on the culture really I'm cancel
culture from local activists against
parents that were speaking up at school
board meetings on things like uh you
know closed schools or masks or critical
race Theory or transgender issues and it
really just took off and you know it was
it was impressive to see just how
everybody stepped up and you know
exercise their civic duty to you know
stand up to what their government was
doing at the local level I mean we
always see you know everyone's obviously
you know focused on the midterms right
now and in presidential years people are
focused on on the presidential races but
in these local political issues
everybody just assumes you you send
somebody to a school board or you send
somebody to your Board of Supervisors or
your local Commonwealth Attorney and
they just do the job because they're not
political well and not anymore and maybe
never but I think now these days we see
it more and more uh and it really just
snowballed to to November of last year
where I mean you had thousands of
parents out at that that final Glenn
Junkin rally in Loudoun County Virginia
and you know while he didn't win Loudoun
County uh I would say that you know that
area was integral in Virginia flipping
but also in really setting off people
throughout the country I mean I can't
tell you how many times how many emails
calls text messages DMS from people
saying how do we do here what you did
there but you're actually seeing it now
across the country I mean you're seeing
you know you look at Dearborn right we
talked about Dearborn and you know the
Muslim Community going out to school
board meetings and saying no and the you
know this this woke culture that you
know Prides itself on we want to create
diversity well yeah they have done that
but they've done it in a way that it's
now opposing them where you have all
these different coalitions that are
opposing their you know ideas that was
their plan the whole time to sacrifice
themselves for the greater good right
get everybody riled up be the villain so
that they all turn on them and focus and
focus in on on their problems but uh
this will be interesting Loudoun County
was like a major Catalyst for a lot of
what we're seeing around the country
especially with schools so thanks for
hanging out we absolutely we've got a
lot more to talk about we also got Luke
hey guys my name is here if we are
change.org I come here to you at one
very simple trendy Yuppie message and
that is two plus two equals five you
bigot now get in line comply or else and
get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
hi everyone Ian Crossland here uh happy
to be here from Ian crossland.net and at
Ian Crossland if you'd like to follow me
on social media but let's get to this
huh.com yeah pressing buttons that's
right take it away Tim all right here's
the first story
Kanye West escorted out of Skechers
office in Los Angeles after he showed up
unannounced yay formerly known as Kanye
West was escort out of the LA office of
Shoemaker Skechers the company said the
incident comes after Adidas terminated
its relationship with the Fallen rapper
and fashion Mogul over his recent
anti-semitic and racist remarks he said
racist remarks like or is that are they
saying Judaism is it's a religion and a
race but is it I I mean is that what
they're saying they're saying that the
one the one thing he said is both or I
don't know if he said something I think
it's about the white lives matter
t-shirt that he's wearing oh okay all
right yeah that's probably right I was
no I was just wondering if it was
multiple statements or are they saying
that you know talking about Jewish Media
or whatever is whatever he said
considered both
so they basically say he showed up
unannounced and has escorted out of the
building yo that's crazy quote Skechers
is not considering and has no intention
of working with West we condemn his
recent divisive remarks and do not
tolerate anti-Semitism or any other form
of hate speech that the company sent in
a statement the company would like to
again stress that West showed up
unannounced and uninvited to Skechers
corporate offices
yo that's crazy he's like Persona
non-grata across the board now for what
he went on Tucker Carlson he's had some
stuff what was it he tweeted about it he
tweeted about the Jewish Mafia he said
that's it you know for the record a
Semite is anyone from ancient
Southwestern Asia includes acadians
Phoenicians Hebrews Arabs so if people
say anti-arab stuff they're they're
anti-semitic just for the record yes
so keep it clean folks yeah so anyway
the reason I thought I mean look this is
Kanye West I said folks I don't normally
say that I guess
yeah no I think it's interesting we look
we were we were trying to figure out
like what are we leading with on today
and uh you've got Elon Musk he's buying
Twitter that's happening so we'll talk
about that you've got PayPal Banning
hate speech but what we have here check
this out with Kanye West
he tweeted a few things this is this is
this is cancel culture check it out look
I I think what he said was stupid
obviously and wrong LA Times Kanye West
hits keep coming here the companies that
have cut ties within the Gap Instagram
and Twitter JPMorgan Chase Def Jam
Balenciaga as I said CAA MRC Adidas Foot
Locker Jalen Brown and Aaron Donald down
to sports oh wow is that it donda was
just talking saying that they were
sticking with him yesterday is this
right his lawyer also uh he made sure
that he's not working with him his
talented his lawyer dropped him yeah his
lawyer dropped him his talent agency
dropped him and now LA Times is writing
writing an article talking about how
Spotify and apple music have to pull his
music and they're arguing for more
censorship more canceling here yeah L.A
times has an article that's titled why
Spotify and apple music haven't pulled
Kanye West's songs and in that article
they make an argument saying if we're
going to counsel somebody we're going to
make sure we're going to fully counsel
this person and you're seeing someone
being depressioned in real time whether
you agree with him or disagree with him
I think there is something to say about
something that is happening to Kanye
West right now that has happened to
other people like Alex Jones and of
course Andrew Tate as well look at this
donda's Kanye's company and Jalen Brown
and Aaron Donald cut ties with donda
that's what it is and they got rid of
the donda Academy basketball team was
removed from a tournament okay what were
you saying no just LA Times here's the
story well Spotify and apple music
haven't pulled Kanye West's songs
this is the crazy thing about censorship
when Alex Jones got censored they didn't
shut down his ability to speak they
deleted everything he had ever said on
the platform on all these platforms
there's no record of it anymore that's
crazy that's like you know that what is
it photo of Stalin and there's that dude
next to him and then they got mad at the
dudes the dude's gone from the photo you
guys don't know yeah you guys you know
what I'm talking about you never saw
that it's like a famous photograph where
it's like him with this guy and then all
of a sudden the guys watched him out wow
yeah yeah back in the day before
Photoshop same in one there's like
numerous people that he just you know
depersoned they got Kanye man yeah
because he said oh now they're gonna get
mad at me for saying they no the The
Establishment the corporate press I
don't think here's the funny thing about
what Kanye said right so he criticized
the Jewish Mafia I think Kanye West is
clearly wrong about that I think he's
putting
needlessly putting like ethnicity and
race in front of what's clearly
corporate interests that are aligned
against him right but this is exactly
what conspiracy theorists and
anti-semitic individuals
expected to see and they and they got it
I got a question do any of you guys are
are any of you guys Jewish or do you
know a lot about Jewish Judaism in
general I talked with Michael malice
about it he's Jewish and was telling me
that there's like a tenet of Judaism and
get correct me if I'm wrong anybody in
the chat I want to get this as clear as
possible but that part of the uh Jewish
faith is that God commands people to
maybe not enjoy life on Earth but take
advantage of life on Earth this is
basically your opportunity and if you
don't take advantage of it then you're
basically committing a sin against God
so Jewish people believe that this is
Theirs to to mold and craft and utilize
but then what happens is that when that
gets out of control it can be perceived
as greed and that's completely
antithetical to Christianity which is
Charity greed isn't is a sin in the
Christian faith so
I think if when people get greedy that's
really the problem and when Kanye is
complaining about people he's
complaining about greedy people whether
or not they're Jewish I don't think is
relevant but it is interesting to point
out these these tenets of the Jewish
faith and I'd love to have Jewish
scholars in here to talk more about it I
found it interesting that they're not
canceling his music right I mean it's
it's it's a different situation when
okay you have a brand you have sneakers
or whatever it is that he's going to be
associated with but with the music it's
just him and so how much of the money
that that he's worth comes from his
music how much does he generate uh for
iTunes for Spotify obviously would be
hugely concerning if we start saying
we're not going to platform your music
um because of something that you said
outside of your music or even in your
music but if that's the next shoe to
drop I mean that's going to be a
problematic thing for everybody when
you're talking about censoring things
like music on on platforms what happens
after that so do you guys see when uh
remember when they banned Farrakhan I
think Facebook banned him basically what
happened is after Alex Jones gets banned
people start pointing out that uh
Farrakhan I don't know if for everybody
people aren't familiar it's the um
what's the organization called uh it's
the Hebrew Israelite no no no the Muslim
Brotherhood no it's not the Muslim
Brotherhood Nation of Islam nation of
Israel there you go that's what it was
yeah so uh Farrakhan has is deeply
anti-semitic there's tons of people in
the rap hip-hop community and many
people in the black community who follow
this he gets banned and Snoop Dogg put
out a video saying how the f are you
gonna ban Minister Farrakhan you know
how dare you and stuff like that and
it's fascinating because it's like you
do realize what that means these people
believe right they're just not saying it
so what happens is people get surprised
Kanye West comes out and says this stuff
I wasn't I was on the ground in
Baltimore during the riots it was I
can't remember who the riots were for
and there were a bunch of young black
kids who were very very talking about
they were talking about Farrakhan
they're talking about Islam Allah and
they were saying anti-semitic things and
that was the first time I ever
experienced it I didn't know I was like
what is this like they're Islam or
what's going on and they both are
talking to me about you do realize like
farrakhan's been around for a really
long time and then I was like oh wow
I've only remember from rap lyrics and
Tony Hawk 2 was a Public Enemy song you
know uh turned it up Bring the noise
that's what it's called Bring the Noise
yeah when uh when when
um what's the rapper Chucky D says
farrakhan's a prophet I think you ought
to listen to in the lyrics and so I
didn't really know a whole lot about it
then I see these viral videos and I was
like that's what these people believe
holy crap so they banned the guy because
people started campaigning saying how
are you going to ban these people but
not him then a bunch of rappers
prominent celebrities people like Snoop
Dogg came out
Kanye West comes out and says I'm gonna
say what I feel like saying then he says
some anti-semitic BS and people are
surprised dude there's a ton of rappers
and celebrities who believe exactly what
Kanye is saying so I don't know I don't
know how you deal with it or or I'm just
I'm just pointing that out you want to
talk about banning his music which is
unrelated to his politics because he
admitted to what he believes think about
people like Snoop Dogg and all those
other people who support Farrakhan yeah
another issue with Judaism and Islam
I've been thinking about is whereas
Judaism has this tentative like take
advantage of Earth utilize its goods and
it's gracious uh Islam is like do not be
decadent decadence is the bane of our if
you are decadent you are sinning against
God so whereas the judeo the Jewish
faith is kind of like maybe an opulence
maybe not the right word but they're
willing to have huge you know a lot of
things and stuff and good good things
around you Islam's like no no no no no
no no you do not want to show if your
brother is decadent he's a he's a stain
on the family so I think that's part of
why those two religions have been at
odds for so long I think
just coming into my mind the other day
yeah well you start you start Banning
music from today's era what do you do
from 150 years ago right that's a good
point classical musicians uh the Baroque
Era what were all their beliefs let's
let's get their beliefs and let's cancel
them off of you know wherever you get
your classical music from it's a
slippery slope that's so it's so weird
good point yeah this is just it it's I
shouldn't break it down shouldn't be
centralized yeah we can't we need like
decentralized music serves like iTunes
should be a decentralized service in the
Commons where everybody can host their
stuff and and be utilized well you know
you know at the other side of this
private businesses get to choose who
they want to work with if they don't
want to work with this person they don't
have to but there also is a very
coordinated organized push to punish
people for expressing ideas that that
they don't like of course ideas always
should be debated always should be
contested uh I'm all for debate but you
know some people are saying Kanye is
going way too far it's too
sensationalistic and there's there's a
big Firestorm happening here there's
there's a lot of of media organizations
saying cancel cancel cancel cancel and a
lot of Corporations saying okay yeah
gladly we'll do it and they are so
whether you think it's right or wrong
that's up to you based on your
individual you know and all this is
going to do is make him double he's
going to double down he comes out and
says he's being attacked by you know a
particular group then all of a sudden
everybody cancels and bans him what do
you think he's thinking right now Kanye
is probably being like see see and it's
like dude yes it's it's it's just so
insane man yeah I'm surprised he wasn't
able to sit down with like the daily
wire crew apparently that's not going to
happen Okay so they didn't want him on
he said that electric on the Lex Freeman
interview he said it and then Alexa's
like wait they didn't want you on and he
was like yes they said they didn't want
me on that's crazy I mean I get it you
have to imagine Ben Shapiro's like dude
not cool I mean it's like you know Ben's
Jewish but I do think communication is
the solution I have I mean unless you're
going to try I want to see a Kanye Ben
Shapiro debate it would be entertaining
it would be yeah crazy but would be a
clash of different ideas and as you
mentioned Tim you know a lot of people
have those kind of different ideas but
but at the same time what better way to
deal with it what better way to to get
rid of a lot of this animosity a lot of
this hatred than to be able to just to
talk things out and be able to of course
pin ideas against ideas let that let the
best ideas win and I think that would be
something interesting it might go
Haywire it might go bad but I I think
that's the consequences we face in our
modern day society and that's better
than just shunning someone and saying
hey now we're going to make sure you
double down on your beliefs instead of
talking you down from the beliefs that
we think are wrong yeah I gotta I'm
gonna have to head up the daily wire
crew and ask them why that's the case
because that doesn't seem right sure
good clarification yeah because the
daily wire they like poking the bear and
and especially with Ben being Jewish and
Ben being reasonable I'd imagine Ben
would actually have a conversation with
Kanye Ben debates people he stands in
front of people so it seemed weird to me
that the daily wire wouldn't bring him
on you think they'd be the first first
place to be like okay Kanye like come
here and tell us why because we're going
to tell you why you're wrong but to just
be like no we won't have them seems
strange to me I don't know man yeah the
point you brought up you know I agree
right but your businesses can make their
choices on who they associate based on
you know what they want for their their
business model but Marketplace of ideas
I don't remember what Supreme Court
Justice said it back in the 30s or maybe
it was Holmes or Brandeis but the remedy
for bad speech is good speech exactly
right so you know absolutely 100 and we
need to prioritize that more more than
ever no matter who it is if you disagree
with again censorship only Fosters those
bad ideas and makes people double down
on them and when you censor people when
you silence people you only make sure
that they go off to the far ends of the
internet where those ideas are even
radicalized even more than they were
originally radicalized this is why I
have a lot of prospects and and a lot of
uh
nap pessimism optimism specifically when
it comes to Elon Musk purchasing Twitter
as I think it's going to help Society by
and large a lot I agree so let's jump to
this story first before we get to the
Elon Musk stuff we have this from grit
daily I'm not familiar with grit daily
and I think they're wrong on this story
here's what they said following PR
crisis PayPal again updates TOS hoping
you won't notice they say as far as PR
crises go PayPal has gotten itself into
quite a predicament on October 8th the
company updated its terms of service to
include a clause enabling it to withdraw
2500 from users bank accounts simply for
posting anything the company deems as
misinformation or offensive
unsurprisingly the backlash was instant
and massive who would have guessed that
the consumers don't want a company to
take to police their speech and threaten
to drain their bank accounts aside from
the fact the Clause is a Fool's Aaron
because there's literally no way for the
company to legitimately determine what
is or isn't misinformation okay full
stop guys they would it it actually said
at their discretion
so he goes on to say it's another case
of big Tech overreach so a lot of people
are pointing it out but let me let me do
this here's PayPal's actual user
agreement it says if you are this is
current right now I just Googled it if
you're a current seller and receive
funds for transactions that violate the
acceptable use policy then addition to
being subject to the above actions you
will be liable to PayPal for the amount
of PayPal's damages caused by your
violations of the acceptable use policy
you acknowledge and agree that 2 500 US
dollars per violation of the AUP is
presently a reasonable minimum estimate
of PayPal's actual damages including
we're not limited to internal
administrative costs incurred blah blah
blah so so there it is they're not
saying right now they are going to
deduct it from your account but it is
there
and right now uh so this is an archive
from two years ago which basically says
the exact same thing you acknowledge and
agree with twenty five hundred dollars a
permanent you know per violation is the
is reasonable minimum estimate here's
what they determine currently to be
unacceptable they the promotion of hate
violence racial other forms of
intolerance that is discriminatory or
the financial exploitation of a crime
so of course that's at their discretion
so let me just stress right now
and you know admittedly this is at risk
to us we still have many members of our
website timcast.com who are using PayPal
if that's you I recommend you uh sign up
using parallel economy send a email send
an email to members at timcast.com we
will do our best to help you get
switched over it's not partake it's not
super easy but uh we used to use PayPal
we removed it from the website but there
are so many people who still do use it
it's still there if you are using PayPal
you need to find an alternative I
recommend parallel economy that's Dan
bongino's company they got a lot of work
to do to get set up it's not as easy
with you know PayPal you click your open
account it's done that's why they
dominate but we've got to get away from
this stuff because right now they said
it right there you agree that 2500 bucks
is reasonable damages if you espouse
discriminatory speech what does that
mean does that mean if I say something
like
um on average I would prefer a male
firefighter to save me over a female one
look like I'm not I'm not going to play
games I think there there's a there it
doesn't matter if you're a male or a
female if you want to be a firefighter
but on average based on muscle mass
bound density and height it's probably
going to be you preferring a male what I
mean by that is there are six foot tall
women who are super strong I'll tell you
this I would rather see a six foot tall
woman than a five foot tall man if I was
trapped in a burning building and needed
help however typically you are going to
see the height skew men are going to be
taller and more muscle mass if I say
that was PayPal gonna boot us from the
web from from our website are they going
to kick off our customers are they going
to charge me now 2500 bucks per customer
what is a stupid game well it's per
violation and they're saying that if you
one of the things they're saying is that
if you incur damage to PayPal's brand so
if I tell people to cancel their PayPal
account I'm technically they could say
hey every every time that that was
uttered every Play that video had if I
have 10 000 views every every one of
those views counts towards an instance
of the violation of of denouncing our
brand like I'm canceling my PayPal
account tonight I've been using it for
20 years and I don't stress it does say
PayPal May deduct such damages directly
from any existing balance in any PayPal
account you control so let me stress
right now at paypal.com
they say they may deduct at minimum 2500
if you engage in a variety of activities
including discriminatory speech
promotion of hate yeah now who gets to
decide what is discriminatory speech who
gets to decide what is quote hate why
are these rules so General vague and and
to the point where it could be
interpreted in so many different ways
they do that because again this is akin
to a social credit score they know
PayPal is one of the biggest online
banking institutions on the entire
internet and right now they're saying we
could do whatever we want we want to
steal money from you we will which is
absolutely crazy will they find me for
having a PayPal account right now maybe
who knows that's how vague these rules
are and again PayPal has been becoming
more of an activist organization more
and more they work with the splc a
discredited organization that has been
successfully sued before for defaming
defaming people for lying about people
they they actually moved out of North
Carolina because North Carolina does
decided to have a policy where they said
biological sex individuals people have
to use bathrooms based on their
biological sex so they're acting more
and more like an organization that wants
to of course play political games and
push their political ideas rather than
of course just be a bank just be a bank
for for Frick's sakes it's not that hard
I just want to point out it's funny that
this policy has been in place for years
and no one knew it was coming but it's
like nobody actually read the terms of
in conditions it was kind of like when
Zuckerberg went on Rogan was like yeah
the FBI asked us to censor and no one
really like it was obvious we all kind
of knew that for the last few years
since he testified but it was like I
think mines tweeted out Bill ottman
tweeted it out I was like yo everyone
focus on this because that's crazy well
everyone focus on this PayPal Clause can
they did they say they can also take
2500 out of your bank account out of
your PayPal account it also says items
that are considered obscene obscene by
who yeah really like like I don't know
we're talking about sexual toys the
other layer here is is not just all
right what are what are they going to
punish here discriminatory speech hate
speech but damage to their brand which
they're saying well we can't really tell
you what the damage to our brand is so
we're gonna put in this little
liquidated damages clause for 2500 so
not only are they determining what's
hate speech what's discriminatory but
also what's damaging to their brand
which none of it's going to be damaging
to their brand but they put that in
there as just another layer for them to
enforce it and saying well this is why
we need to do it there these rules are
damaging to their Brand It also says
Luke you might want to earmuffs this one
it says content that relates
transactions involving ammunition
Firearms or certain firearm parts or
accessories blasphemy absolutely
horrible I mean that that right there
just shows you how much of a political
organization that they are how they're
just playing again
social justice Warrior politics that
they're trying to push for the Forefront
in reality people just want a bank
people just want to use Finance people
just want to be able to trade and barter
and of course make money and sell money
and and sell products why are we having
to deal with all this nonsense why are
they putting these rules into place
that's a question that I think a lot of
PayPal users should be asking themselves
today I used to feel like I needed a
PayPal account because paying online was
really a hassle I'd have to put in my
bank card I have to put in this now that
data saved for me I don't need to go
through it's like do I want to pay with
my car that's saved in steam or do I
want to pay with PayPal it's like 50 50
coin toss I don't need PayPal I don't
need it for anything at the moment I
don't nothing and then they have things
like stripe which are which are doing
the exact same function newer better so
privately owned that's why we use stripe
and we we default parallel economy so if
you want to become a member at
timcast.com using parallel economy
supports the company which is Dan
bongino's company we use Rumble
infrastructure for everything and you
support us directly so I'm very excited
about it too I got a question I mean I
see a copy of uh genderqueer there does
does that mean that somebody would
violate PayPal's rules if they um you
know sell that book or promote that book
online well that's only determined by
the people that are running payroll
definitely no technically yes but it
does say uh sexually oriented materials
or services well it says it says certain
but it's obscene a lot of people
consider that obscene so if someone you
if they use PayPal to transact that wait
doesn't it can't you use PayPal for
Amazon or no can you I think so yeah I
think you can oh we got a problem here
PayPal Amazon is outright violating your
policies because Amazon sells a whole
lot I haven't used it in a while but I'm
gonna do it right now and see if I can
pull up a PayPal cool man I've left I've
had PayPal for 20 years why are these
companies getting political is our
PayPal's always been bad well Elon
started the thing Elon and uh what's his
name Peter Thiel Peter Thiel guys how
they exploded onto the scene well that's
how they got a lot of their you know can
you buy using PayPal Ian on Amazon
you got to be able to right I think so
yeah I don't know I'm not sure there's
also a lot of gun accessories on Amazon
as well that are available to purchase
um but but I think a lot of this
correlates with the ESG score it could
be people at PayPal being like hey we
want more investment money hey we want
more Federal Reserve BlackRock money hey
how do we do that let's just do exactly
what they want us to do and implement
the ESG social credit score system where
of course we comply we push all the woke
nonsense we push all the politicking
onto the individuals and we make sure
that of course we play along with the
game that the globalists and other
centralized Bankers want us to play I do
not see uh PayPal on Amazon to be honest
I oh okay maybe not yeah maybe not maybe
not because otherwise they'd be
violating their own policies but let's
talk about the solutions man Solutions
baby take Let's uh let's take a look at
the story here from timcast.com Elon
Musk tweets video editoring Twitter
headquarters updates bio to Chief twit
as deal nears closing this is huge let
me let's see if I can uh you can't
really see the video it's very small
but it's just uh Elon Musk laughing as
he carries a sink into Twitter
and he says entering Twitter HQ let that
sink in
oh I get it wow he's the cheesiest dad
jokes man but he earned it so he's not
throwing the kitchen sink at it this is
about let it sink in this is all for
that all for the joke I guess is he
gonna wash the wash the dishes is he
going to clean the place up I mean is it
all these he's gonna fire 75 of the
staff did you see the demands they sent
a demand yeah they're ludicrous but they
was like they weren't asking him to do
stuff they were just demanding that he
does they were like with the demands
don't fire us it was really yeah I was
like let us work from home I think don't
be eraser don't be racist was one of
them don't stop us from working from
home don't be politically biased that
was my favorite one oh wow see that's
exactly what it is Colin Wright tweeted
this he was like it's going to be funny
when all the woke left flip and now
support or and now demand the government
intervene to stop private companies from
setting their own rules demand
preservance of benefits
um demand leadership and sure Fair
Severance for all workers
uh demand transparent prompt thoughtful
communication around the working
conditions some of these you would think
he's going to do anyway but as soon as
you start demanding of your owner like
what you should probably you know you
should do he should turn off Twitter
from like
yeah I don't know what like five to
seven every night he just just turns it
off and it's like everybody you have to
watch something else you can't use
Twitter don't read a book go read a book
yeah he turns it off for two hours calm
down everybody go on and then everyone
just starts like shaking and they're
getting ah no if he did that they just
go to Instagram or something yeah they
demand that he preserves the current
head count they demand that he doesn't
fire them what in the heck you know what
I'm really jealous of Elon Musk you know
why
because he gets to fire these people
like just imagine how much fun that
would be no no for everybody doesn't
imagine you're Elon and you walk into
Twitter HQ and you get to walk through
the whole building you can you're a
billionaire so you can fly in a private
jet to any one of your satellite offices
and you get to walk through and just
look someone right in the eye and go you
get out
it's lucky you know these people making
the demands I mean what were what were
their home lives like when they were
kids were they making demands of their
parents or their parents yes you know
just fully saying
sure I probably yeah right I mean we'll
see lots of parents doing that snowplow
parenting when the parents bulldoze
everything out of the path of the kid so
these these kids grew up with no
obstacles and they expect to be handed
everything that's why they're confused
the government isn't just giving them
free food it's why they say things like
there's more empty houses than homeless
people so let's just put them in the
empty houses and then you're like do you
know what one plus one equals like you
put up you put you put a mentally ill
person in a house how long until the
house burns down falls apart who's
supporting or sustaining who's paying
taxes who's funding it who's going to
cover the cost of the fire department
these people don't think these things
through and it's because their parents
walk them through everything without
giving them any obstacles and
participation trophies everywhere they
go five things elon's talked about is uh
not letting people remote into work as
much and I I worked social media and I
found like that was the best part of the
job was being able to work from home at
my on my own time limit and we didn't
have to be in the office together so it
it was like and then we actually we got
an office in Brooklyn and it was just an
expenditure we didn't need it we found
out after a year we're like why do we
even have this thing we don't need it so
I I don't know I hope that he's open to
letting people work remote but he thinks
that I think what he said is that unless
if the people aren't there to have
oversight over that they don't work
properly and that might be a good
argument
why why let people work remote I mean I
understand there's some circumstances
where it's probably fine but most people
probably shouldn't commuting is is
lengthy it's time consuming and
expensive too bad and so is having an
office if you don't need one if you
don't want to be here you probably
shouldn't be
that's what I always say so when you
know if there's somebody who's like man
I want to work with a company but I'd
rather not be there I'll be like well
then you're not going to work here I
don't get it like you want people who
who are passionate about the project
they're working on like um oh yeah for
sure for sure so right now you have
Millennials and gen Z quiet quitting
have you guys heard of this yeah yeah
they're basically like it's a
combination of ideas one way I've heard
it described when they're trying to make
it you know politically correct is it's
not not working it's just doing exactly
what you're asked and it's like okay
well that's nothing that's called doing
your job what we're saying is don't go
above and beyond it's like okay yeah
well you know no one's making you do
that some might ask you but if you don't
want to fine but typically quiet
quitting was referring to people who
were quitting working without saying
anything to keep getting paid as long as
possible until they got fired that's the
mentality of these people so
that's what's happening right now at
Twitter a good majority of people work
there probably do not do work wasn't
that the Veritas thing that that audio
or someone's like I work four hours a
week
this is going to be very exciting I'm
I'm I'm optimistic about this I'm
skeptical because the man still wants to
sell robots and put brain chips inside
of your your skull but at the same time
he did tweet today that he's quote a big
fan of Citizen journalism he also
tweeted how citizen journalism is
dismantling The Establishment bias and
then went on a tirade and went as far as
to even call the New York Times a quote
chaotic actor causing problems in our
society so uh he didn't say that exactly
he said that uh you know just in the
general sense of what he was saying here
so so I'm excited for what he's going to
be doing I'm excited for the
opportunities that are going to be
presented because he's he's essentially
promising free speech he's essentially
saying Hey The Establishment has gotten
it wrong a lot of people have been
censored before we need free speech more
than ever I'm willing to put billions of
dollars into this what's going to be the
result of this I don't know I I hope
it's going to at least help mend a lot
of the bigger problems in our society
because I think it can because the
larger provide and Conquer agenda that
has been pushed on everyone the larger
disinformation the larger censorship
efforts have been causing a net negative
towards our society you could solve all
of that just by allowing people to talk
freely and with him already cheering on
citizen journalism independent
journalism trying to of course promote
people who are trying to hold big Powers
accountable highlights how this could
potentially be something that could be
amazing and world's changing yeah I
think that what one of the things that
will happen is that Twitter uh parlor
when Kanye buys parlor and mines with
Bill ottman's minds are going to
Federate and interoperate start to
interoperate along with Rumble Chris
pavlovsky's Rumble which is already
working with starlink to uh Interlink
their servers and starlinks networking
capabilities to get global internet and
actually
solar internet like we're gonna have a
planet to planet interplanetary internet
and you have all these networks start to
be able to interoperate Jack Dorsey
wants Twitter to be a protocol meaning
that you're unbannable it's
decentralized everybody can post no one
has control over what you say and the
only thing can happen is if it's illegal
then the police can deal with it if Elon
Musk does implement that we know that
Jack Dorsey was talking with him behind
the scenes before he decided to buy this
that is a strong possibility Elon does
move towards making it a protocol it
does then merge in a sense with with
Minds as a node or with Rumble gab uh um
parlor truth social even and then the
way it would work is and this is the way
it absolutely should be
you have a Twitter account
it's Twitter servers so they could they
could ban you on their server but if you
turn it into a protocol your username
goes onto whichever server you want it
to be on so if you're using gabs servers
you know they're not going to ban you
unless you dock someone or violate uh or
break the law so you're like I'd rather
be hosted there but I'm on Twitter I can
follow Ian gab.com and then I get Ian's
tweets on Twitter even though he's
posting on Geb and Twitter has no say in
it it's almost like reverse RSS I
suppose it could be that's the way it
should be he's also talking about
allowing end-to-end encryption when it
comes to private messages and as an
independent content creator as an
independent journalist I'm going to
pretty much go all in I'm going to
invest my time and I think this is going
to also move the market in a way that
that I think is worth talking about
because if you have a platform providing
Free Speech providing something that all
the other big big Tech social media
platforms aren't providing he's going to
push the needle he's going to be very
competitive in the market because now
Facebook Instagram all these other large
corporations Google YouTube are going to
be looking at at him like Hey we can't
hide the cat in the bag anymore hey you
know these ideas are still being
expressed they're not being censored
here the more we censor them the more
obvious it becomes because now on
Twitter we have a platform that of
course is allowing the truth to actually
get out there allowing real
conversations to get out there without
an algorithm without Bannings without
censorship without restrictions on
speech this is going to I think in my
opinion if this is done as Elon Musk
says he wants it to be done shift the
market in a net positive when it comes
to overall freedoms and speech yeah I
just gotta I gotta I gotta throw this
out there because I I I would be I have
to
Elon Musk Joe Rogan me let's talk about
Twitter's rules censorship it'll be the
Twitter the Twitter Rogan episode 2.0
I I obviously you know I'd love to make
that happen because I'm the lowest on
the totem pole of the of them Elon of
course the richest guy in the planet Joe
Rogan the biggest podcast in the planet
then the little old me so I'll I'll say
what you know hey come on guys like
let's let's get a show going
um I'd imagine they probably care very
little but I do think it would be really
epic to sit down and discuss twinners
and Twitter's internal policies plans
bias censorship imagine this if you guys
watched when I was on Joe Rogan this is
back in like 2019 with Vijay God and
Jack Dorsey and everything I said and
everything they said
give Elon Musk a month or two of
actually going through the internals
then sitting back down and saying okay
Elon which of what they said was true
and which of what they said was a lie
and then have Elon just be like oh they
said this that was a lie they said this
that was a lie and then to go through
policy procedure philosophy ideology
would be incredible but we're also we're
also going to find out what was I I
think this is a big possibility of
finding out how else was was Twitter
manipulated we're going to find out
about the Bots we're going to find out
what they were doing we're going to find
out about their algorithm we're going to
see what an uncontrolled social media
platform is unless the FBI doj and U.S
intelligence agencies come to Elon Musk
and kind of proverbly put the gun to him
and say hey you're going to do what we
want you to do look at this Drew
Hernandez says apparently leftists are
fleeing to this new Twitter alternative
called tribal social network wow dude
they've posted that they don't censor
they just have an algorithm that bans
bigotry it's like okay dude like
go for it I don't care I hate it so you
could say two plus two equals five
that's right all right I don't know
entertaining I want to piggyback off of
your idea from earlier Tim about being
able to log into your Twitter account
and follow me on mines for instance and
I think it'll even be better than that
in that you'll be able to lock you'll
basically your account will be your
wallet it'll be like your your crypto
wallet like a metamask account or
something like that and you'll log into
social networks with your wallet and
that will also help you bypass things
like PayPal or your bank Like A Banks
and things like that these these weird
like top-down authority figures trying
to eyeball your accounts
um and it'll it'll it'll create kind of
a
a parallel economy so to speak a
parallel culture yeah for sure it's like
the fist coming breaking out of the
ground of dirt you know it's it's
awesome I'm down all right let's talk
politics man let's get into it because
last night we sat here begrudgingly
listening to John fetterman failed to
speak terrible it was horrifying it was
horrifying and now we have this from
timcast.com supporters double down on
fetterman accused critics of ableism and
bullying did you guys see the view clips
when they were like I thought the
Hippocratic Oath was Do no harm Dr Oz
was bullying fetterman bullying he was
having a debate it's a political debate
he's supposed to be like you're wrong
John at any point did Dr Oz say
fetterman has brain damage no what are
they talking about these people have
lost the plot they're willing to they're
willing to put in the guy who clearly
his brain does not work welcome to
Modern politics I suppose they hate you
so much they and and I mean it's I'm not
trying to there's not an emotional dig
or anything it's factual they hate
Republicans they hate Trump they hate
Maga to the degree that they would vote
for someone like John fetterman did you
watch the debate oh I absolutely watched
the debate it was it was tough to watch
yeah I mean you know we're talking about
somebody that's gonna be one of a
hundred senators in the United States
Senate potentially that said he's going
to vote you know to break the filibuster
to end the legislative filibuster and
this is someone who cannot answer a
question on his point of view for
fracking and explain were you lying then
are you lying now or did your position
evolve we got no answer I mean we got a
long pause no answer and for people to
say well it's it's ableist I mean the
same people that said you know if when
Mike Pence was debating Kamala Harris
you know if he challenged her on
something well then that was
mansplanning right it's the same thing
if you're a conservative and you
actually argue your points and they can
somehow you know turn it into well we
really can't argue with you with what
you said or that argument isn't really
going to work so we're gonna you know
say you're you're a mansplaining you're
an ableist
um you're you're racist you're uh uh
insurrectionist whatever I mean just
pick from the the cookie jar of of
things to throw out there what is
ableism it's discrimination against
someone who is differently abled
I'm going to make an ableist t-shirt out
of all these discussions about ableist
two plus two equals five you ableist so
I'm gonna be thinking about like a
disability shirt that only has like one
or no sleeves
well as I understand ableism it's I
wasn't supposed to be a joke I'm like
are there people who have like one arm
you know do they wear shirts with an
empty sleeve like what do other shirts
that just don't have one I mean that'd
be cool right it would be cool actually
able not ableless what's I guess that
yeah that's the thing they're still able
those people are still able the whole
disabled like yeah and things might be
more challenging but you're still able
right you know you still got your
abilities but that's the PC idea the
disabled just referred to someone who
has a disability they used to call them
[ __ ] I mean the word they're called
invalids yeah the words have evolved
over the years George Carlin nailed it
yeah you guys ever see that bit where
he's like
post-traumatic stress disorder we used
to call it shell shock but then the
words keep getting more and more verbose
the phrases get longer and longer he I
think he mentions invalid but then
people are like no no you can't say that
that means invalid we can't say that so
then they create new words like [ __ ]
but then apparently those become
offensive and now there's disabled
meaning you have a disability it just
meant like you didn't have your your
hand was injured your foot was injured
your eye your ear because on average a
person has two eyes two ears two arms
two feet two legs Etc and and now that's
offensive so now it's you're not
disabled you're just differently abled
that's not true man come on this PC is
so dumb if you have if the average
person has two hands and then someone
loses a hand that's not differently
abled it's disabled I got no what's
what's the deal I guess if someone's
born with three hands they're more abled
whatever it just depends on how
society's geared to function because if
you have like 27 hands you're you're
that's a form of a disability because
it'd be hard to navigate well the PC
progression language you could climb
trees and stuff you nailed it right so I
remember 20 years ago I'm law school
reading the case Oliver Wendell Holmes
he's going through the categories of
mentally disabled people at the time at
the time which is you know the early
1900s and you had [ __ ] idiot and
imbecile right and those were the three
different categories but then they
became associate associated with you
know they you can't use those anymore so
then they they came up with the term
mentally [ __ ] right that eventually
now you can't use that so we move on to
something else and then whatever we're
on now Divergent you're not yeah people
use that in 20 years that's going to be
over yeah that's going to be over too so
we'll find out a new term well well so
neurodivergent is what they use for
mental ailments yeah but the problem
with that is Divergent implies not
normal so you can't say that right I'm
I'm I'm I'm setting it early let's make
neurodivergent extremely offensive
because it implies there are people who
are not normal you're not Divergent you
are the way God created you right
there's no word you can use for anything
where you cannot find something right if
you're one of those people that are
perpetually offended you're going to get
offended by every word that is either in
the dictionary now or will be in the
next you know Millennia my favorite was
uh wimixin and women do you know about
the wimixin thing no so it's woman but
oh yeah yeah instead of Ian it's xn and
they said the X means it's inclusive of
all women and then people were like what
do you mean inclusive all women women or
women and they were like oh but like
wimix and means you know like women of
color and trans women and then other
leftists were like are you saying that
they aren't women and don't just fall
into the word woman and then fighting
broke out one organ organization said
not using the acts as offensive the
other side using it was offensive then
somebody used an I then somebody used a
y and then here we are got no idea this
is look this is Idle Hands the Devil's
Playground these people have nothing to
do with their lives they have no skills
no talents no passions so they make up
fake garbage to fight for because they
have nothing else they have no Great War
they have no great challenge that's it
many of them don't have kids if they had
kids they'd be too busy to be doing with
doing these things they need a boogeyman
if they don't have a boogeyman they have
no one to fight and since you know the
there's a more demand for for sexism
racism than there actually is a supply
of it and I think that's very clear
especially with this latest uh kind of
uh bastardization of our language
especially when you see just how you
speak it is how orwelling it is exactly
almost from 1984. but but back on the
fetterman kind of topic did you see this
real quick no I did that fetterman
blamed the captioning device oh wow okay
I'm just gonna say it because I I've
been saying this the captioning device
isn't going to work the technology is
not that advanced it is hard for
computers to transcribe Voice to Text
well so I knew this was going to happen
happen they're blaming it next star came
back out and said hey like we gave you
the special technology you asked for I'm
gonna put it this way fetterman's
campaign said the the captions were
filled with errors right there fill with
errors okay you should not be in that
job because there's no technology better
than the live news captioning system
it's like having someone's blurry vision
be a fighter pilot you wouldn't do what
was very interesting is seeing fetterman
raise almost a million dollars from his
performance last night I actually
watched Philip DeFranco and he talked
about this he admitted he didn't do that
well but he really wants him to win
that's what he said
Franco said that is wrong with these
people and then DeFranco and Hassan both
today were talking about how horrible Dr
Oz is because Dr Oz didn't allow
journalists to actually record the the
the screen that actually projected the
words on there and they weren't able to
fact check exactly what was on there and
it's Dr Oz that's responsible why is he
responsible that's what they're they're
pointing the finger at him because he
denied uh fetterman to have journalists
looking at the screen to fact Jack that
it was accurate that's the arguments at
how Cutthroat things are and with the
world sometimes
um I don't know what about like playing
softball for Global political dominance
is not a victory strategy this look I've
been you guys ready you got your shot
glasses ready this is why I've been
talking about Civil War for so long a
sane rational human being is looking at
the facts and saying please I want to be
correct you know what do I if I make a
mistake let me know these people don't
do that for Phil DeFranco to come out
for I'm sorry Phil not just you but for
anyone to come out duck Federman
actually didn't it wasn't that bad you
know there's like slate wrote actually
Federman did pretty well the Philly in
choir saying he did great like yo and
he's saying human watch that and went
wow yeah
well just watch right without the idea
that he had a stroke that he didn't do
that well but he's still out of that
performance came out on a show and said
I really hope uh fetterman wins that's
my point they hate you so much facts be
damned they would put a man who can't
understand words can't speak and would
blame his assisted listening device if
it bro if you they're tweeting out as a
senator all you gotta do is say yay or
nay so fighterman can do the job that is
not the job of Ascender you have to
represent the state to the federal
government they would they are gutting
and burning the system to the ground so
I do not see a scenario where we move
forward as a country when you have these
Psychopaths saying you know what I don't
want to be on the outside and I assume
this is the inside so I'm not backing
away from this we're coming to a point
where it's going to be clear as day with
with all the polling with all the
projections let's assume they're right
maybe they're not maybe maybe Democrats
really are going to win I have no idea
if Republicans do win if and it's a
landslide and we see more of Democrats
agreeing with Republicans and
independents these people still will not
back down because they're in a circular
firing squad as Obama calls it Phil
DeFranco will never admit fetterman
should not be in office and Dr Oz is
tepid at the at the very least he's he's
middle of the road celebrity doctor is
that the worst you could do no there's
worse but he would rather say fetterman
because he knows he's got leftist
activists with their finger on the on
the flag button who are going to ban him
on social media unless he says what they
demand he say I gotta I gotta bring it
back to John fetterman because John you
gotta first of all man heal heal up your
family needs you your wife your kids
they need you man and
it you know do your best and if that
means that you need to heal for three
years do it but like it's important to
keep the compassion for John alive we
want him to I want him to be healthy but
I also were voting for a senator right
now so let's put all our cards on the
table forget about the pass look at that
debate as is without knowing any prior
he has this past she has this he has
this injury like fetterman was
stuttering and bumbling and vacant for
much of it I don't want a senator that's
stumbling bumbling and vacant and at one
point the the moderator did say Oz
question question but it was actually
meant for John fetterman and there's a
long pause and John was like oh oh so
that's on the the modern there's one
instance where she said Oz and then
asked fetterman the question and John
was really confused uh it's about
two-thirds of the way through the
interview but maybe that's why he froze
up because he's reading there is one
instance but he throws up on other ones
too where she directly that was a seven
second break in one question where he
just freezes like and you can actually
count and I I went on the timestamp it's
the one where he goes oh and then
answers yeah that's the one where she
says Oz first let me let me jump to this
projection because uh here it is right
here from RealClearPolitics battle for
the Senate Real Clear Politics as
Republicans winning 53 seats Democrats
47 Pennsylvania they are saying Oz is
going to win and no question they're
saying no question they're also saying
Georgia Arizona and Nevada
there you go
well you know what's interesting about
that 53 number is it's bad for Democrats
obviously in 2022 but it's awful for
Democrats in 2024 because that map is
very disadvantageous for Democrats in
2024 I mean you look at places like New
Hampshire Pennsylvania West Virginia
Montana Georgia specifically Georgia I
don't know if Georgia is up in 2024
Michigan Wisconsin Minnesota all those
States they're gonna lose more seats in
two years they put up federmanium he's
going to be the guy that breaks the
filibuster Republicans are going to need
a filibuster in into after 2024 if
things break their way in these next two
election Cycles now they may not but you
know this is this is what happens I got
it I really do think there are two
things you can say to somebody let's aim
in 2024 is I don't know if it's possible
do you know do you know how many Senate
seats are up in 2024 it's got to be
third it's a third a third okay so it's
possible that we could see 60 Republican
seats we need what like 63 or something
let's get let's get 66 Republican seats
in the Senate and then just you know run
rough shot just just pass all the bills
ban all the garbage and I think maybe if
you go to people right now and say gas
prices that's number one but the other
thing is while you're talking to people
and you go like gas prices are really
really hurting you right let me show you
this you know I got this thing here
about gas prices and like oops I
accidentally pressed plan this video of
Biden supporting sex changes for
children
I think those two issues are going to
make people jump ship because when CBS
did their panel with the Democrat
Republican and independent what did the
Democrat woman say I've got a bunch of
kids and what's happening in these
schools is bad and I don't like it I was
talking to my mother over the weekend I
went back to her house trying to hang
out for a few days and Becky I'm gonna
put you on blast I was like you know
Biden grabbing young women and smelling
them and like telling that one girl wait
till you're 30 before you get into a
serious relationship like that's scummy
dirty and if I went to the park and did
that to a little kid I'd probably get
thrown in jail she's like he did not so
I showed her the video I showed her the
picture she's like
he shouldn't be touching little kids
he should not be but he's not going to
show you that it's up to us it's and
that's why Elon buying Twitter that's an
October surprise what if one week before
the election Alex Jones
milianopoulos Laura Loomer Donald Trump
they all come back and then and then
they're surfing on that red tsunami
I wonder if that'll have an impact I
mean these are loud voices I think I
mean there's a reason they were censored
there's a reason you know not just
right-wingers but also people on the
left a lot of anti-establishment types
were censored because they're not
censored because they were wrong they're
censored because they were a threat
towards the current narrative towards
the current agenda and they needed to
silence those voices in order to make
sure that their agenda their narrative
could go through it without even
question without even being questioned
without being stopped at all and I think
this is why we had so much lunacy during
the last two and three years because no
one could have challenged it you
challenged it you got banned right away
this is again why I see Twitter as a net
positive
possibly moving forward well you know
it's interesting you talk about that
focus group right and people saying this
this stuff that that's going on in
schools well look it's been out there
for a long time now but it's just it
could never get traction on social media
could never get Traction in the
mainstream media because they didn't
want to talk about it they didn't want
to offend the far left that thought this
was all great but where it all starts to
come out is when you've got you know
little Johnny with his Chromebooks
sitting home from school and then Mom
and Dad also sitting home from school
working and they were like what we never
heard about this and then people start
digging in and then you start activating
all these people and you cannot you
cannot unring that Bell right now and so
that is that is an exact point when you
have gas prices where they are inflation
where it is you know threat of war with
Russia over Ukraine and he's talking to
you know a guy that's pretending to be a
girl in the white house I mean come on
you know I watched that and says that
person is Faking It
is intentionally trying to insult trans
people and women and there's nothing
anyone can say to convince me otherwise
Blair white said no I know people who
know him and and you know Dylan is
actually trans and I'm like there's no
like
that's I just don't buy it I think I
think Dylan Mulvaney's whole bit and
I've talked we've talked about a couple
times is intentionally trying to insult
trans people it's it's it's you look at
these videos and you're like that is
look at videos of your average trans
person that is not what Dylan Mulvaney
is doing like Blair white is a is an
example of a conservative I think the
player's conservative I assume Trump's
supporting and then you look at Contra
points the two examples left and right
they do not act like that this Dylan
Mulvane he goes to the White House and
says extremely offensive things come on
like Dylan Mulvaney made a video about
how he's he's got a bulge and everyone
was staring at it like that I'm telling
you man this person is trying to make
trans people to insult trans people and
and their and and Dylan's probably
laughing every time he puts a video out
because conservatives are watching it
saying look how crazy they are and the
left is being like we we better protect
it it's like that that teacher you saw
the high school teacher with the big
fake tits yeah some people are
suggesting that was a troll and I saw
that maybe it was a trial I'm like I
wouldn't be surprised oh I mean look I
gotta be honest I mean maybe Society is
collapsing people are losing their minds
but I really think when you look at the
the there are a lot of people who are
trans that are not prominent and you
might not even notice and they've been
around for a long time then you look at
Dylan and everyone assumes that's what
trans is I'm like no Dylan is just
intentionally it's a character it's a
caricature it's a mockery it's a it's a
it's akin to a Minstrel show and there's
nothing anyone can anyone can say to
convince me otherwise because
Blair White's not walking around talking
about Barbie pouches like what is that
even word hiking heels dude she doesn't
make her personality about her gender
you know it's a show Dylan is doing a
show it's fake fake fake anyway look
Luke I gotta I gotta ask you this
question uh-oh look at this map
what am I pointing to right there what
is that New Hampshire what what color is
that I don't know I might be colorblind
I can't I can't really what color is
that Luke what is that what color is New
Hampshire Ian correct who's the governor
of New Hampshire it's blue it's blue New
Hampshire how is New Hampshire voting a
Democrat senator in Bernie Sanders no
he's Vermont he's Vermont I don't know
and he's independent anyway who runs
that I guess I don't know much about
that race that's happening in the Senate
there but I do know the governor there
sununu now here we have it oh Governor
red what happened oh yeah I'm sure I
don't understand how you get a red
governor and a blue it's the free state
project
a lot of uh they call them [ __ ] a
lot of people moving up from
Massachusetts and uh changing the
landscape there but that's right I don't
think it matters what political party
you affiliate with personally I want
good people I don't care what label you
slap on your shirt hey I'm still a big
fan of the free state project I think
they're doing incredible work and I
think a lot of them especially with the
homeschooling Network down there is
doing incredible stuff that I think
should be replicated and cop copied
everywhere else their meetups their
Community is awesome going strong and
doing really really incredible things
you know so they're not affiliated red
or blue Republican well they're they're
in the local government there's a lot of
uh you know free Staters in uh the the
state representative uh local
governments there that are implementing
local laws local jurisdictions making
sure that you could actually get raw
milk uh ice cream that was one of the
big hurdles making sure that you could
carry your firearm when you're on an ATV
and there's a lot of other legal battles
especially when it comes to taxes and
tax credits especially from
homeschooling that they did have very
significant victories on by coming
together and working together on those
issues what was the no gun on an ATV
problem they were New Hampshire had some
weird law where you couldn't have a gun
on a snowmobile or ATV and they of
course repealed it with uh work of the
free state project in local government
see this is what's what's what's brutal
is them I pulled up 270 to win state
house elections map only 31 States
so
Senate and and uh representative State
legislatures it's only 31 States going
Republican New Hampshire of course has
read free state project Maine and
Minnesota are considered toss-ups so
we'll see but even then it's only 33. we
need a handful more man what do you need
like 30 37 or something for a Convention
of states
yeah I think it was uh who was it that
we were talking about oh it was uh Doug
mastriano I mentioned hey Convention of
state so then we can fix everything he's
like be careful with that because they
can use that against you too people can
call Convention of states and like
change laws they can't right you still
need to have vote gun rights so we we
talked to the Convention of States guys
they were on the show and they said it's
not what happens the convention of
States allows a convention to occur
whether they make proposals and then
they have to vote on the changes to the
Constitution they don't just do it does
it go to this it doesn't go to the
Senate bypasses the Senate it's the
states only so the state so it would
have to be the Republicans voting and
then my question is if the Republicans
convene a Convention of states is it
going to be Republicans Banning 2A or
are they going to be like we reaffirm
and re you know rein you know restate
the all I mean like the NFA outright
violates the Constitution
we just as a society just allow these
things to happen the funny thing is
most I I should say the problem is most
people don't care about their rights
being eroded
that's it
like like everyone's being spied on
nobody cares it's that subtlety that
people don't it's when you don't
perceive it you know a little bit like
erosion slow erosion
uh is unnoticeable almost but when a big
huge chunk of land breaks off that type
of erosion everyone freaks out about
well that's one of the points I brought
up earlier with like local local issues
right most people are not tuned into
what's going on locally they'll tune
into the national stuff because it's on
television all the time right you need
to turn on Fox or CNN or whatever
Network you want to watch and they're
going to be covering the Senate they're
going to be covering the house they're
going to be covering the presidentials
but maybe you have 10 of people on on
the right and 10 of the people on the
left in these local elections that
actually care and then they show up to
the extent they do in these low turnout
local elections and they're just
guessing they don't know anything about
these people because they're not paying
attention they're busy with soccer
practice they're busy with school
they're busy with their day-to-day life
but that's where it all starts right all
these people that are you know running
for these big offices now all get their
start at the school board the county
boards all these local offices and they
get in there and they start moving on up
and if people don't pay attention to
what's going on locally that's why we're
in the problems we're now what kind of
commitment is it to a be local official
I mean it's it's low paid uh like if
you're a school board member you get
paid twenty thousand dollars a year so
you're not doing it for the money you
may be doing it because you know you're
an activist and you want your policies
in place or more likely than not you
you're a political climber and this is
your first step to the next step so you
right off the bat you've got to start
you know paying the favors that you owe
and making sure that you're appeasing
your base and and playing politics at
the local level
do they convene weekly monthly is it
every day how often does a school board
member for instance uh every two weeks
you do like what like six hours they do
they do like a yeah about a six hour
public meeting and then they have
committee meetings which are often you
know they could be virtual they could be
in person it is a lot of work for them
to do it
um so you know when you have people
doing it it's I kind of break it down as
to you've got the true activists you got
the political climbers you've got the
people that are actually went there
because they believe in in public
service and then you got the people that
believe in public service but have been
so beaten down by the first two that
they're just you know checking in and
checking out
and that's what local government looks
like so should we pay a million bucks
will that make sure that the people are
there for the paycheck and not for the
activism
I don't know I don't think that's a real
solution I just think that it's always
going to be activists the problem is
where are our activists who want to be
there yeah I'm doing the show personally
like you're doing a show what are you
doing here Ian maybe you should be out
I'm thinking um but I do think shows
like this are massively influential
because you can get a lot of people to
vote the way you want them to vote when
10 000 people are a hundred thousand
people hear your voice although imagine
you know 10 years from now Ian's
governor of West Virginia
and we're like remember when he was on
the show and then he decided you know he
got to do something and now he's the
governor and constitutional carries been
enshrined and at the federal level Ian's
running for president you know what I
don't like about governorship right now
is that they can decide for their state
if it's abortions legal or not one
person
chosen by the government no the governor
who decides State Legislature so how
many people is that depends on the state
in some states it's 50 some states it's
300. is the governor involved in that so
it depends on the state some some yes
some know uh in some states with the way
it'll work is the state house will
propose a bill they'll vote on it if it
passes it goes to the state senate who
will vote on it if it passes it goes to
the governor Governor's deck and desk
and he can say veto or a sign veto but
not in every state the governor doesn't
have veto power does Governor I don't
know about every single state I think
like Nebraska is an assembly structure
and some states have like a senate I
don't know it depends on the state man
but they basically function like
similarly to the to the to the federal
government I get edgy over top-down
Authority but what do you think about
governance right now do you think it's
like do you like the way it's set up uh
yeah I mean it does depend on the state
but do I governance generally locally
nationally
what are we talking Statewide governance
with a governor at the top president at
the top of the national government that
kind of that kind of yeah I think you
need it I mean I think you need you know
it's it's federalism right if if you
have too powerful of a state legislature
you're dealing with the same issues you
would have if you didn't have that check
and balance at the national level
checking Congress right if you don't
have that at the state level there's a
lot of things that get done at the state
level that don't get done at the federal
level the federal government will try
and get those done but most of the
consequential stuff that affects your
day-to-day life happens at the state
level so if you're flipping every you
know every which way and you don't have
those checks and balances in the state
government as well your lives going to
be impacted so we had Amon Bundy on last
week and he was saying that if he
becomes Governor he's going to make
abortion illegal basically and that's
just a vague you know that's him saying
is a policy plan and he's going to
advocate for it and then hopefully get
to sign it advocate for it I get you
advocate for it to this to the
legislature then they get to decide what
to do with it okay saying if you get
this to my desk I will sign it you think
you'll ever run for State office no any
kind of office you have any no
aspirations right now never definitely
not where are you going to run first I
will say right now there will never be a
circumstance where I will ever run for
public office I don't know if I can help
people with public I mean I bet I could
I think what is the job is a lot of
listening
like you go in and there's 50 other
people that want to talk so it's just
wait and listen to everybody the power
is going to go to your head you're going
to do mandatory DMT trips for everybody
I could see it now but I mean if you do
breathing to incite the DMT Rush yeah
dude holotropic breathing that's one way
of doing it
every single person who turns 18 has to
go to a next go go in for Extended State
DMT it's like a three-day thing where
they put you on a on a bed with the IV
drip for DMT and then a screen comes out
of the floor and it's Ian's face and
he's like you can do this I don't want
to do this man you have to do this
the Aztecs did that before obsidian
ritual cutting hearts out and stuff the
resistance the resistance breaks into
Ian's Palace chamber and they're like
it's over Crossland we're putting an end
to and then he hits a button and it
sprays dmtl on their faces and they're
like Luke do you have aspirations to run
for office I I I hate politicians I
don't want to hate myself that much and
no hell no
um I just I just don't see it I I see
more positive change being done by by by
by media rather than being in the
political office yep culture
culture is very important right we've
had governor candidates come on the show
but I've never been to their Governor's
Mansion I mean I'd go there look around
take some pictures well there's
candidates they don't have Mansions okay
who's more influential you know uh
Tucker Carlson or like your your local
Congressman yeah I mean that's that's a
question that I think is worth asking
Tucker for sure Tucker I mean it depends
celebrity a celebrity aoc's a celebrity
she's really like fallen out of the
Limelight a little bit the Democrats
have really lost any
they haven't got anybody like you know
we said AOC the other day as a Lister
but it's like she's really not getting
the press these days no not at all yeah
the squad's gone but the Republicans
keep getting it see this is the fault of
the Democrats who chase after the the
far right they say they made it so that
Lauren bobert MTG Trump DeSantis are the
news and now nobody cares about their
candidates so sorry guys you think
you'll ever run for office Ian no I mean
I I agree with that I think that I mean
first of all if you run for office to be
really good really good you need to say
this is what I stand for and I am not
going to let the pressure get to me
where you start you know compromising on
your views and and then you start you
know you just lose who you are while
you're running for office and it happens
to a lot of people it doesn't happen to
everybody but you see it happen and I
see it happen all over the place where
you're like oh well that person said
that because he was in a crowd of people
that that think that and he doesn't want
to lose that Vote or she doesn't want to
lose that vote and then you just you
know it's it's sort of a natural
reaction I think for people and there
are other ways to to sort of influence
policy to influence you know culture
um Beyond just running for political
office I think you have to have that
that
um the right characteristic right stuff
to run for office I've never thought
that I would be that person it happened
to AOC she was talking about how big and
bad the military-industrial complex was
now she's one of their biggest
supporters and funders right these
people are pathological Liars this is
why I I hate election season they're
lying through their teeth they're full
of crap on almost every single issue and
I don't care if you're a Democrat or
Republican there's very few people that
are able to actually impress me and talk
about the real legitimate issues that
actually matter instead of just giving
me generalized platitudes that don't
amount to jack-ish and only amount to
them trying to get you to support them
and whenever you're a human being that
puts your power your energy whenever you
put someone else above yourself you're
committing an act that that shouldn't be
respected you shouldn't be a simp for
politicians you should believe in
yourself you should Empower yourself and
at the end of the day one person who's
going to fix all your problems it's not
going to be that politician it's going
to be you when you decide you had enough
of the bull crap and you're going to
make changes and decisions in your life
that actually benefit you instead of
giving up all of your power to Mr
douchebag or Mr turd sandwich but it
wasn't it just so much easier just to
not think about it Lou no just give up
yeah when when you see the atrocities
when you see so many human beings being
poisoned being screwed over being
absolutely robbed of their wealth robbed
of their Futures no it's it's not easy
because the amount of hurt that
politicians are putting on the American
people doesn't amount to any form of
laziness or convenience that just by
voting them in but I wonder if that's
just part of the system the structure of
the system that people have because
you're saying like every almost every
politician becomes some sort of
is that I wonder if it's all of them
either that's a problem with Humanity
which maybe but I don't I want to think
better than that that it's a problem
with the way the system's set up that
people all of a sudden they get some
votes and now they're they have more
power than you maybe it should be that
they have ability to alter what are we
going to say yeah so I liken it to this
right so you've got your your network uh
shows right your your sort of mass uh
consumption sitcoms and they're on
broadcast right and they do well and a
lot of politicians are like that but
then you have your really good shows
smart shows that are still able to
achieve success you know it could be on
HBO could be on any of these other
platforms so you still do have that but
you have to really be able to balance
you know popular appeal but staying true
to your ideals right that's that's what
makes a not just a good politician but a
good elected official we do have a lot
of these you know generic broadcast
network shows that are bound on
television you see the promos for them
when you're watching the NFL over and
over again for 20 years that does make
up a lot of the political class you
think there are elected officials that
aren't politicians
I think they're elected officials that
will engage in being a politician to get
to office and then actually do the job
that's required of them but being a
politician and being a you know a
candidate I mean you've got to make
phone calls and ask people for money
that is the worst thing in the world I
don't know how anybody ever does that
I've got a pack out and loud and fight
for schools I used to have to I called
some people last summer to try and raise
money for you know our recall efforts it
was horrible you know you're like yeah
can you give me uh what can you can you
well I'll give you 200 that's oh that's
awesome thanks for like what did you
only ask for 200 yeah I can't ask for
more that sounds horrible I don't know I
know but I used to do non-profit
fundraising and I would always this is
what the average person comes in so I'm
doing this canvas thing they'd be like
can you give
five bucks a month and they'd be like
okay and they'd be like okay and then
I'd be like why don't you ask for a
hundred I can't ask for a hundred
dollars I'm like you kidding let me show
you it's done I walk up to a guy and I'm
like we want you to sign up and I've
I've got like a trainee and they're like
What's it gonna cost I'm like I'd like
you to give me a thousand dollars per
month and then the guy just laughs like
are you kidding and I was like oh no I
want you to give me a thousand dollars
per month otherwise who else is going to
help us stop deforestation and the guy
goes oh I can't give you a thousand
dollars I'm like how about 100 bucks he
goes I can do a hundred and I'm like
you get what you ask for that's that's
the thing but I get it man fundraising
is brutal so I think that's another
reason I wouldn't want to be I would do
it like via internet video you know but
I don't even know if it violates
YouTube's terms of service but of course
you could have your own social network
and work off minds and things like that
yeah this I I don't understand that
politicians should just be putting out
broad spectrum videos where they're like
I need you guys to donate today here's
why and then just do like a 10 Minute
Podcast YouTube video social media put
on all the platforms that's way more
effective than picking up the phone and
calling random people
but then they they use the pick up the
phone system to be like well that means
I need to hire 10 people which means I
need to raise this amount of money
because you you don't need money to be a
YouTube Star I did I when I started I
had nothing I had a 60 30 webcam and a
15 microphone you know how you win these
days it's like think about anything
they're doing they're going door to door
it's like just film everything and post
videos making phone calls buying
commercials a commercial is less
effective than you making your own video
that goes viral for whatever reason
so you know when Bloomberg was running
he put half a billion dollars or
whatever into this race and all these
YouTubers started getting tons of money
and they're like that's just I guess
when you're a really unpopular guy with
really horrifying ideas you have to pay
for it but if you're a politician you
want to run you got good ideas you can
just do all earned press make make
YouTube videos you don't need to spend a
single dime on it Donald Trump
his it was all earned press he spent
very little money relative to uh to
Hillary and other candidates because
they just kept talking about him on the
TV ain't how to do it
but that wasn't even him making his own
YouTube videos nowadays you could just
make your own YouTube show and be like
hey I'm running and give me money
yeah I mean think about this people are
members at timcast.com so that we can
make more shows and we're not even
running for office
so you know people are willing to sign
up to help to contribute you just gotta
be
better at it I guess it's always driven
me nuts how like the great politicians
are the people that don't want to do it
they're like I don't want that power I
don't want that it's not right but then
you're like but you have to because
you're the right guy like you're the one
that will put it down when you're done
with it
but no one's gonna force you to do it so
unless you take the reins and make
yourself go so Ian
I mean to do politics you would have to
you're up against the global and then
you take the military into account and
it's like oh my god do I want to be in
charge of who lives and dies I mean I'd
rather me than somebody else but I want
everyone to imagine Ian sitting at the
Oval Office desk justifying why they had
a drone bomb at Pakistani Village that's
so gross
no but you like think about the kind of
person you could imagine saying
something like that but then you have
real threats where like there's an
invasion force it hasn't happened really
in our in our modern history to the
United States we don't have any yeah we
do haven't had a real invasive threat
what do you mean the United States we
yeah several years people are Marching
In in the tens of thousands with their
Flags I would have sent the National
Guard out night too yeah that's what
Carrie lake has been saying National
Guard man Carrie lake has been calling
for the National Guard to go down and
stop The Invasion the Border dude and
the cartels now you want to talk about
an enemy you do not well I don't want to
make enemies with cartels who are on our
but we've got like a drug uh what do
they call it a a narco terrorist State
on our Southern border like The Mexican
government is the cartel essentially and
they're it's like the cartel is a form
of government that operates but they're
intergovernmental I mean you've got
cartel operating even up in Maryland and
you know up in that is freaking yes
that's true haven't you ever watched
breaking bad dude has it always just
been military Authority since the
beginning I don't remember looking at
history I don't know of a time when it
wasn't military Authority first and then
everything else well yeah we're in a
bubble
I mean it's a crazy thing dude you just
because I I got to say it I've been
reading about the Civil War and
there was no Lincoln suspends habeas
corpus from DC up to Philly up up to
Pennsylvania basically because Maryland
was a slave state so they're just
randomly arresting people this is why
the the four states in 1861 in May
seceded because Abraham Lincoln was like
I'm not gonna allow these seven states
to secede we're going to use Force then
four other states Tennessee North
Carolina Arkansas Virginia we're all
like yo we're not gonna We're Not Gonna
Stand By and let you do that it was
brutal but it was war
you know what do you do when War when
War breaks out
everything else is is just
words on paper you know you you can come
out and be like I've got a
constitutional right to this set or
otherwise and they're going to be like
yeah well we're being invaded by you
know China or whatever so I don't care
like we in the the United States
interned Japanese people like that is
certainly not constitutional didn't
matter
Wars War yeah did it anyway winning
so if it really does break down and get
crazy people don't understand how crazy
can really get everybody tries to base
what they think is happening in this
country off of what's already happening
right now what happened in the past but
you know what man what people really
don't get
every single War there's a there's a
there's a this technology has advanced
in weapons and so when the next War
breaks out people are taken by surprise
at the weapons that are being used so
just consider this
you have the invention of rifled muskets
and even breach loading uh rifles in the
Civil War and that that increased
accuracy of the rifles by like 400 for
percent so now bayonet charges don't
work and and many groups tried that
imagine where we go now imagine if a war
actually broke out what do you think
we're going to see it's not just going
to be AR-15s there's going to be weird
things there's going to be drones
there's going to be a DJI drone and it's
going to be carrying a a small payload
and P and it's going to fly up and then
zoom straight at you and explode there's
going to be people with microwave
cannons so like active denial systems it
shoots microwaves at people so it makes
them feel like they're on fire laser
weapons lrads tiny tiny drone bullets
that are going to be controlled and just
fly into someone's head and blow up
that's right suicide it was first tiny
tiny little bombs yeah that all they got
to do is go right to your iron natural
disaster weapons yeah yeah tsunami bombs
Consciousness weapons like weather
control weather modification weapons
what is it silver silver iodide is that
what they use yeah that's how they seed
clouds right to make to and they can
also use infrared lasers that was a
study in Germany that did this they
pointed lasers up and it condensed
particles creating clouds now how would
you use that during a war
um Make It Rain too much in an area
that's just that's destable or like
unstable rather or can't handle that
much rain
eye rain cutting out solar power or
block the clouds or block the Sun as
Bill Gates is trying to do himself a
real Matrix Bill Gates is trying to do
it Mr Burns yeah yeah yeah there's a
scientific project that was supposed to
be tested uh it didn't go forward but
it's going to go forward later on that
literally is going to block out the sun
you got a name on that by any chance
um let's let's look it up I looked it up
uh I was talking I was researching this
about like eight months ago so it's
still in the back of my head but uh uh
block here just from CNN yes what does
it say What's the title a radical
proposal on climate change block out the
sun yeah and this is project that Bill
Gates is Harvard scientists yeah Bill
Gates funding and funding this all in
the name of you know climate change and
green energy Bill Gates Venture aims to
spray dust into the atmosphere to block
the Sun what could go wrong Yep this is
a Mr Burns and this was supposed to burn
this was supposed to go forward as an
official test a couple months ago it was
postponed but the test is still going to
be going forward with Bill Gates
literally blocking out the sun because
of
a climb it I pictured Bill Gates
literally a 100 million miles wide
blocking up the sun when you said that
no no he's got a remote and when he
presses it a gigantic metal disc goes up
we just don't he's just you know he's
just an unaccountable billionaire and
businessman that buys off the corporate
media there's nothing to worry about
here it's not like he believes there's
too many people in this world oh wait oh
yeah this is the kind of sun burns
easily and that's really what it's about
he's like a pasty white dude and he's
like
he does wear a lot of sweaters he's like
say yes you know maybe he's you know he
gets like eczema or something more
magnesium Bill get more green vegetables
that's how you avoid sunburn
you know I mean I don't think the dudes
eat vegetables I think he's just he
wants to block out the sun I'm thinking
you know that sounds so villainous yes I
know yes what do you think I've been
screaming about this person for the last
10 years 10 years I've been like hey you
guys should look out at this guy hey hey
this guy's doing this he's doing this
he's doing this he's doing this he's
also trying to create microchips that
are going to be artificially birth
control inside inside of human beings
that that's all concerning stuff that we
should be talking about especially since
we got here talking about the new kind
of weapons that will be used during
World War III because there's also a big
potential hypothetically to say that
this war is already going on and a lot
of people don't even realize it anymore
and that right now people are dying
people are casualties of this war from
circumstances and things that they don't
see that they might be participating in
and consuming themselves for sure
viruses you can't see them that's a
great War tactic food if you poison food
or make food that is poison that's a
kind of a war tactic but it's just like
a subtle war no one wants to be the
aggressor in that war they don't want to
be found out as an aggressor you'll lose
public support so you always want the
other side to be the aggressor
right and then weapons
you know would be really funny if like
world war three is just like the US is
bombing itself and blaming Russia and
Russia's bombing itself and blaming the
us but that's all it is and they have a
secret deal an arrangement being like
hey guys we're going to Wag the Dog here
we're going to Stage something but we're
going to work on this together so we
could feed the military-industrial
complex but we're just going to play
pretend here well I mean like
hypothetically the uh I think it would
be funnier in the scenario if the U.S
there's no direct conflict it's them
attacking themselves but we were a
bombed today and it must have been
Russia but it's like the CIA it's false
flag after false nothing but false Flags
Russia is like so so I mean think about
what happened right now you've got this
story where Russia apparently is going
to blow up a dam and there's and so
Russia says Ukraine is going to blow up
a dam so Western media says that's a
signal that Russia is going to blow the
dam up to blame us like this is how
insane it is so like all of a sudden the
Ukrainian Dam explodes and then the the
Western media says Russia did it it's a
false flag they're they're trying to
blame us then all of a sudden Russia
blows up one of its own dabs and goes no
no this proves that Ukraine did it
because even we got attacked and so
everyone's just blowing themselves up no
you got to get public support I guess
but let's get to the point where the
robots fight each other you know I think
that's already happening too or or you
know you could just deny Humanity energy
and watch you know civilization collapse
on itself we can watch food prices go up
so it becomes too expensive so people
can't afford it you could stop domestic
energy production and exploration just
like the new prime minister who's also a
part of the world economic Forum a
Goldman Sachs Banker just banned
fracking inside of all the United
Kingdom also the same individual pushing
for a central bank digital currency uh
which is akin to a social credit score
that his family is also invested in
heavily and working on of course
building with the world economic Forum
this is what's this guy's name the PM of
Rashi Rishi Rishi sunak and he within he
just got in with like two days ago yep
and he's already banned fracking oh yeah
yeah the entire Globe United Kingdom yep
one person and they're already getting
ready to to ration uh heating oil for
the winter and this is the same person
by the way that that just talked about
how the UK is going to be the first
place that is going to rewire their
entire Financial system in order to be
Net Zero oh this is the same guy
literally promising hey we're also going
to bring in a central bank digital
currency because it's going to be so
convenient when the government's able to
watch track and see every little thing
you do and tax you automatically without
you even having to fill out any tax
forms this is this is a new level of
orwellian 1984 New World Order Brave New
World that we are all facing today that
that a lot of people warned about saying
hey this is coming now this is a reality
it's like a a a a big do-over you know
like a big
you know Grand like Grande
reformatting that's yeah reformatting um
a new
a gigantic New Beginning a restart right
restart is that something like that like
a reformat like a Reaper big rebirth I
was studying the the revolution you know
the American Revolution the first one
and uh I say right now because we're in
it right now it never stopped
um George Washington would go to the
Continental Congress they'd all go you
know they'd sit there and Washington
would barely ever speak he'd just listen
and he'd be wearing his full military
outfit and they're like yo this guy's
ready to roll like it was before the War
Began but everybody knew George was
ready to go and he shows up in full
military again they're like dude come
back finally when they make their
decision that they're gonna have to go
to war with England
um John Adams is like we've decided
who's going to lead the Army and John
Hancock's like he's the president of
Congress he's like here we go give it to
me boys and then uh they were like and
it's George Washington and Hancock's
like deflated he thought he was going to
be the guy and George didn't want it he
was like this is a suicide mission I
can't there's no way we can win this
yeah but he did it anyway
and thank God for the French how many
how many battles did he win
I mean you can count Trenton as a battle
maybe but I I think other than that I
don't know if he he won a single one
other than Yorktown I mean all he did
was fight lose stay alive Retreat keep
going over and over and over again you
know obviously the French come in at
Yorktown they have Saratoga which was a
big win but he wasn't there but you know
sometimes he's sometimes that's the
winning stress you you know so that's
what you got to do makes a good
Commander Mel Gibson won a couple he did
that's right yeah yeah he trust both his
kids though right I know well he had a
bunch he died did he no he didn't die
though no he wins in the end that
movie's so good Washington won six
victories at the Boston a Siege of
Boston Harlem Heights Trenton second the
Battle of Trenton uh Princeton and
Yorktown and he also was defeated six
times Long Island White Plains Fort
Washington brand new one in Germantown
and he had a tie two ties at White
Martian Monmouth but yeah he basically
just held the line for the French to
come win the war for him no one can do
it alone no that's the question about a
Civil War in the United States a lot of
people on the right think that uh it's a
[ __ ] come on the right has guns they
have more military
but people don't understand that
you know when I was reading about North
Carolina I was reading a bunch of uh
historic historical articles from
universities uh North Carolina Virginia
they were split they were like they
didn't want to secede from the union the
protections the union offered was too
great there were benefits they just want
to leave and it was only after 75 000
troops were called upon by Lincoln that
they were like that's way too much for
us we're not we're not going to support
that that's theoretical but it's split
if something were to happen in this
country you might be thinking like nah
there's no way the state would leave
like there's not enough States it
wouldn't split but there might be some
states that just look I'll put this away
Donald Trump wins in 2024 he's president
2025
California Oregon and Washington all say
outright we will not abide by federal
law pertaining to abortion or sex
changes for kids or schools and then
Trump says they have totally cut us off
so we're sending in the Army invoking
the Insurrection act something that
we've already discussed as possible
or let's say antifa starts rioting and
then Trump says we're going to shut down
these rights this time I'm not making
the same mistake the I'm invoking the
Insurrection act and then California
says we can't we can't do this is too
much Trump's sending troops now the
media obviously sides all with these
these Progressive States pushing the
cause of secession I mean that's you
know what we push it to is if they try
to Institute a draft for some sort of
offensive measure in Ukraine stats would
be like I am out I will not tolerate
that I don't know I don't I don't know
uh I think red States but if Trump if
the GOP wins we're not going to have
that if the Republicans win the wars the
war is effectively a non-issue for us
and Ukraine is going to lose in two
seconds
no world war look I'll put it very
simply if Trump wins and if we survive
in 2024 and World War III doesn't start
I don't think it will I hope not if
Trump wins
if Republican wins well I'll say this I
can't speak for the Republicans but if
Trump wins our involvement with Ukraine
is done Ukraine loses the war overnight
Russia walks in it just takes what they
want
it's better than World War III what are
you think Ian is that possible
well I mean I I don't know if you saw
the story the other day where even the
you know the far left Progressive caucus
is oh yeah oh you know let's let's back
off what we're doing now then of course
you know they got yelled at so they had
to had to back off it but this is not
something that you know the majority of
conservative support even those on the
far left I mean their conscience is we
can't support this I mean this is the
political class in Washington you know
that have been there for years that you
know going back to you know World War II
really
um that is pushing this yeah was it 20
or 30 Representatives I'm not sure how
many I think it was it was it was a
significant number coming out against
the escalations in Ukraine which was
which is big news and should have been
covered more right but this is always
how it happens right where you have one
one spot it's like what was it Serbia in
World War one right was it Serbia where
everything happens from there right now
not everything is is World War II where
you have you know a dictator on the
March invading countries you know you
have conflagrations like this that that
set off things that once they once they
happen you cannot roll them back so
hopefully hopefully you know after
November this thing starts to get rolled
back because you know we're we're kind
of at this this brinksmanship
um which we've seen you know throughout
the Cold War which fortunately never
erupted into anything beyond these proxy
wars
um but you know hearing thought talks
about we're approaching nuclear
Armageddon or we could be looking at
nuclear Armageddon the fact that more
people aren't talking about that
I mean that's that's crazy to me
absolutely this is the first I heard of
the progressive uh out outcry about it
yeah who was it was it like AOC people I
don't think AOC Paul
um uh Jay Paul I think was the one that
sent the letter
um so she's a member of Congress uh and
then a day later you know they were
throwing staff under the bus and they
you know for for sending this letter
it's I mean you didn't think this
through you didn't you know either you
write it you send it you stand by it or
you don't send it but I mean within a
day it unraveled sometimes when I see
stuff like this I'm like is is there a
powerful spaceship hidden in off the
Horizon where you know like these
progressives they can't actually do
anything good the Democrats have no
choice is there some great and powerful
demonic entity or a super being or a
multi-dimensional creature that is
forcing them to be evil garbage I just I
just understand why you can't just be
like the war is wrong here's my letter I
don't care it was the Congressional uh
Progressive caucus that officially sent
the letter we should have some of these
individuals on uh with how close look
out look how look how cowardly they got
though they back down they apologize
they they all the BS they play come on
dude I bet there's a lot of behind the
scenes stuff be interesting to air that
yeah but I want to know what the hell
happened because they sent the letter
and then they had to backtrack why did
they have that what pressure to
de-escalate the situation these people
are escalating masks
beat board wouldn't do that is going to
be a Ron Paul uh and cap libertarian and
freedom fighter that's going to progress
Human Society so we are going to be
equally and and promote freedom and and
and really uh be the best human beings
that we could be I I I'm optimistic
Jimmy Dore is calling him out and and
the the fake woke cult left despises it
but Jimmy's right yeah I want to know
what happened I want to know if it's
like a lobbyist group or if it's uh if
it's a corporate group or if it's an
intelligence agency that came to this
Progressive caucus and said stop it
right now who did it why I want to know
uh and I think the American people
deserve an answer because it's their
money going over there it's it's their
money escalating in this situation I
agree so let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only show we got
some big news up for this members only
show you're not going to want to miss it
that'll be at timcast.com so become a
member using parallel economy as our
default payment processor so you will
not be using PayPal
because uh we are trying as much as hard
as we can to build something outside of
all this so again smash that like button
Let's uh let's read some super chats
so lay cucumber lime says good night
everyone
before the show started
that's how fetterman started and you
know this one's kind of obvious he meant
to say good evening right evening and
night in his brain see this this goes to
show you that he is having a cognitive
defect it's not just auditory processing
his brain pulled the wrong word
in his mind evening and night are the
same thing so he's at night but good
evening is a greeting and good night is
a departure it's a goodbye a farewell
brain don't work
all right what do we got
Kermit says Raymond g Stanley Jr this is
to honor those families who got Justice
today
Brooks guilty on all charges banks for a
name drop Raymond that's right you guys
saw that
yeah Daryl Brooks yep yeah guilty on all
charges
all right
crumbules crumulus says joined the daily
wire Backstage Live stream before Tim
cast IRL only to hear Ben Shapiro say
that there is nothing morally wrong with
a man copulating with a frozen chicken
well certainly that that can't be
correct
was he quoting someone else
or has Ben lost his wife
he is promoting a lot of crazy stuff out
there
I want to give Ben the benefit of the
doubt on this one I I gotta know more
let's go deep
let's see
Triton 54 says he speaks in riddles he
drowns in red can't find a Fetter mahen
can't find a Fetter in my hand is that I
don't know it's like a Pearl Jam song
that's better man yeah they're quoting
the lyrics from better man better man
can't find a Fetter man oh I get it fed
her in my hand
oh yeah
all right well let's read some more
amenfi says going to close my PayPal
this weekend I'm tied to their nonsense
and their treatment of Eric July was
over the line re-upping my timcast
membership with parallel economy on
November 1st cheers glad to hear it
that's a Dan bongino company so you're
not just supporting us you're supporting
him we're we're all here to build that
parallel economy man
the god king mem says Tim I took your
advice after 34 years of living in
Seattle we're done as you read this I'm
driving from Seattle to Dallas Texas for
good currently somewhere in South Idaho
peace out Washington State we Audi uh
the good thing is more the people who
are actually moving to Texas are
actually voting Republican which is
actually helping the state shift more
red that along with the Rio Grande
Valley so it's a good thing I think you
know Rogan moving there he's going to
bring a lot of Industry which is going
to be more Progressive
I don't know who uh who Rogan's gonna
vote for if he I I assume he's voting
Republican because he even said that on
his show but a lot of people who are
moving to Texas are going to vote
Republicans so
better than nothing better than nothing
all right let's see what we got
Xeno rabbit says I think we've
officially lost the First Amendment
agreed
powder pz says I am Jewish and I 100
support Kanye what they're doing to him
is evil
well there you go
waffle Sensei says wrong Ian Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood taught us that
greed isn't always bad greed is also
what you what you use to cherish and
protect the people you love and are
responsible for yeah Pride isn't always
bad either and that's a sin in the
Catholic church I I agree greed isn't
always evil so this is uh you should
have you seen full metal Alchemists you
should watch it there's uh I won't spoil
it too much but they're monkey homunculi
artificial humans okay and there's one
each representing the seven deadly sins
so the point he's making is the
character greed is sort of a villain but
also kind of not you know an interesting
point is made about greed in that you
know you should watch Fullmetal
Alchemist Brotherhood Man full metal
it's fantastic yeah yeah really good
stuff
good politics yeah and and even the the
the original Deep deviant anime version
because the manga like stopped and then
they made so there's two different full
metal Alchemists you can watch they're
both good but brotherhood I think is way
better Luke you should you should
definitely watch this too because it's
basically about the government is
sacrificing people to make themselves
Immortal so they're like you know eating
babies and stuff
probably not far from reality what are
you eating there I think I had one of
those little protein bar oh yeah it's
real meat epic
yeah very good chunks of you're saying
the second Full Metal Alchemist is
better than the first one so the the
they're both similar uh they're both
basically about government conspiracies
to become immortal sacrificing people
but uh Brotherhood is the complete
finished storyline which makes more
sense and uh I just think it's better
but you know I'm I'm gonna spoil a
little bit it's basically about
a plan to sacrifice humans for you know
immortality yeah it's basically sort of
but for power yeah for more power I'll
give you the I'll give you I'll expand
upon it because this is interesting for
those who might want to watch it
in the show they they do alchemy in
order for Alchemy to happen you need you
need there's the Law of Equivalent
Exchange that means if you want to make
something it has it has to come from
something something can't come from
nothing
but with the Philosopher's Stone
seemingly things can come from from
nothing
basically as it turns out I'll spoil a
little bit of of it for you
these people who have these philosopher
Stones something isn't coming from
nothing they actually contain like
thousands of dead people whose like
bodies are converted into Mass so they
can use alchemy to mass-produce stuff
and it's a crazy show it's really really
good I wonder if someone has a
hydroxyapatite crystal ball which is the
hydroxyatitis the bone is the crystal
that your bone is made of a human bone
crystal ball that'd be cool
all right the pizza guy says here's 20
bucks for the uh for the fully cooly
Reference last night also I made a video
lining up Alex Jones Joe Rogan rant with
Full Metal Alchemist figure you'd find
it funny since you're a fan look up Alex
Jones explains Full Metal Alchemist that
sounds pretty funny
all right we'll we'll get some more
Super chats
Gabriel Martinez says Luke it isn't
ideas Kanye is speaking from personal
experiences he's getting canceled
because what he is saying is true who
can't you criticize
I I always hated that that quote
for you know people people have claimed
it's um you know that there's a quote
it's like if you want to learn who
controls you just looks you can't
criticize and they claim that it was
like Nietzsche or someone like that but
it was actually like this white
supremacist guy it's also a really dumb
dumb quote because you you like Society
doesn't tolerate criticism of a lot of
weak you know it's like crippled
children it's like they're not in
control of the world that's that's the
argument if you criticize them people
would get mad at you as well but uh I
don't here's what I would say about
Kanye the comments I'm familiar with
he's wrong
um I've already talked about if he's
referring to when he says like Jewish
Mafia like 10 people that he has
colloquially calling the Jewish mafias
like okay
and the reason people are mad as Lex
Freeman brought up is that it invokes
these stereotypes from the past but uh
apparently someone mentioned that in the
full Lex frema podcast I don't watch the
full thing I watched I watched you know
maybe like half an hour of it Kanye
apparently said really awful things that
they're saying yeah he goes off a little
bit on Jewish people
um yeah basically it's so weird like he
didn't specify as eight people that he
works in his inner Business Circle that
all screwed him over at once and they
were all Jewish and those eight people
that's what he was saying that's one
thing I said Alex was like still doesn't
mean that all Jewish people are away and
Kanye was saying he didn't mean all
Jewish people yes he did say that I
think at one point he's like I want to
apologize to the people that I had that
had to be hurt from hearing this and
it's I don't know like we gotta ask
Kanye what if you said Irish mafia or
look I get it I get it you know it does
invoke these old stereotypes that and
and conspiracy theorists who believe
like immediately their response to what
he said is the people who believe that
there's like a Jewish cabal control in
the planet that come out in droves and
start saying this stuff that's why I'm
like bro you know yeah I mean even Nick
Cannon he said a whole bunch of things
so we're like you know basically back in
Farrakhan forever that's exactly it yeah
yo if people realized how widespread the
Farrakhan stuff was they might be like
hey wait a minute it's not just Kanye if
you're mad you know all right Corn Pops
hairy legs says Lincoln was a devout
white supremacist you don't know the
Corbin Amendment the moral tariff and
more get Thomas De Lorenzo from mises on
your show to talk Civil War you know
very little for the amount you talk
about it I know I know very little I've
watched a handful of documentaries read
a few historical scholarly articles and
there is and and this is Broad surface
level stuff but uh sure Thomas De
Lorenzo De Lorenzo from mises caucus you
know we'll bring them on let's let's get
him and Dave we'll talk Civil War
that'll be fun yeah absolutely oh yeah
but white uh I've I've read a long time
ago some of the Lincoln letters or
whatever I can't remember it's been it's
been like a decade but dude was like
seriously racist but literally everybody
was segregation persisted in this
country until the 1950s anybody who
thinks the north was like anti-racist or
whatever or believed in equality you are
wrong yeah we were talking about the
letters right before the show The
Lincoln letters that were pretty
eye-opening look at look at the history
of Liberia dude people were racist men
seriously racist the core one amendment
was a constitutional amendment passed in
1861 by Congress never ratified by the
states that would have banned the
federal government From abolishing
Slavery yeah in the states where it
existed at the time I was actually
reading about that earlier because
um
there was I think it was New York mag
wrote about the failed amendments and I
think there was like 10 000 that have
been proposed but like of course people
are always trying to propose amendments
and that was you know one of them
all right orangelo says Tim I became a
member at timcast.com today and I'm
excited for my first Live members only
show thanks for all uh for you and the
crew do it's not the members only show
isn't live it's recorded we end the show
we record it we upload it so it's video
on demand for all of you but you can
comment and we're going to be doing a
contest soon for our members where you
may be able to win a new car I say may
because we've talked to the lawyer about
it because like yeah I won't say too
much you got to be a member we talked
about it last night
all right cork gaming says Luke I'll
sign up if you get parallel economy I am
I'm in the process of doing that
um and I'm I have the all other
alternative right now as well so it's
all in the works it's going to happen
hopefully soon
um doing all the behind the scenes stuff
it's been in the works for a long time
for Luke uncensored Luke uncensor.com
yeah all right leguma the gayen says I'm
a Jew the Crackdown on yay is idiotic
and destructive he must be publicly
debated for the truth to win muffling
the voices of narcissistic attention
seeking fools gives them legitimacy and
annoys me how this is not obvious
sunlight is the best disinfectant I
agree not only that but the actual
conspiracy theorists seeing all of this
happen are now holding up signs saying
see see look what we said this is not
the way to deal with it man Kanye is a
beloved celebrity he says something like
this then you need to be like okay Kanye
let's let's have a conversation and if
apparently he was saying he was
referring to only eight people I mean
that seriously changes the context of
what he was saying
great Point great comment and uh you
said it more eloquently than what I was
trying to say earlier Ryan Brown says
canceling my daily wire subscription
since they want to be hypocrites
that was but look I don't know if that's
true that they're not having Kanye on
it's just a rumors so uh you know
they said and he reiterated it but well
you know without the specific that's one
side of the story don't feel like you
need to jump to conclusions in this
situation it's a long yeah watch the
video yourself and then come up to your
own conclusions
yeah I'm a fan what the daily wires
doing so you know I'll reach out to them
and see what what's going on there's got
to be a reason these are the the daily
wire guys are not scared you know what I
mean well Ben Shapiro still has a lot to
answer for especially with his promotion
of something um about two years ago that
I think definitely needs to did you see
his video today yeah no yo Ben Shapiro
came out Furious over the vax mandates
the policies the the new uh Revelations
that have that have emerged the lawsuit
in New York so he he went off on it yeah
and that's what I said I like dude I
don't I'm not I'm not mad if someone
trusted was trusting and got taken
advantage of but he should explain why
he spread false information he should
explain why he was wrong and he should
at least admit it and talk about it
because it affected a lot of people and
during that specific time he made a very
bold statement he said get it you dope
uh he he said it's gonna stop
transmission and and in reality come on
you know well the New York Court ruled
that it doesn't stop transmission Rocky
server says Naruto sucks Mark again
zalves for Wisconsin Congress Congress
Georgia district 7 Gwinnett County
Freedom First candidate running against
fake incumbent carpetbagger JK Naruto's
red you almost lost me like opening that
I was like you think I would you think
I'm gonna Advocate oh it was a joke okay
you're cool
Naruto actually was a really really
great show until like the very end with
the great ninja war arc when when like
aliens showed up and it just didn't make
sense anymore and I was like what is
going on and that's like they were
traveling between dimensions and caviar
is an alien and I'm just like dude
you've lost me on this yeah that's crazy
too because
um for the entirety entirety of Naruto's
run I was reading or as available the
scanlations every Wednesday I'd be like
all the new scandalations out and I
would read the latest chapter of Naruto
and then it just got to the point where
aliens and you know I'm just like I'm
not gonna watch I finished the series
but now boruto I'm just not interested
in any of the weird stuff
all right what do we got
Wyatt kaldenberg says Ian are you guys
planning on making a Roku app for your
website I would be interested
interesting if subbing if I could watch
your shows on my TV you talk about
timcast.com uh yeah that's what my
thought was too probably and I believe
so yeah that ultimately that decision is
up to Tim but I think you've mentioned I
have seen the Prototype timcast mobile
app and then after the mobile app comes
the Ott stuff so it looks like the
mobile app may be maybe done relatively
soon I'm excited I was back in Ohio like
I said over the weekend and I wanted to
show my parents timcast.com but they
didn't have it on their TV so I was only
had to show them the YouTube clips from
uh yeah cast Castle I mean they have
YouTube on the studio right I don't know
it was challenging to get to
Carl Schneider says looks like elon's
going to need to buy five thousand five
thousand dollar participation trophies
five thousand dollar ones
all right all right where where are we
at
Miguel Dees says all humans are
susceptible to in-group preference and
collusion Jews are no different with
great power comes great responsibility
you know I think that's you know an
important thing to point out that every
every group is acceptable as they said
to in-group or other preference the
issue that when it comes to things like
what Kanye West said with like Jewish
Mafia or going Defcon 3 on Jews which
was a mistake a misspeak he meant Defcon
right I know the problem is that World
War II wasn't that long ago and it was
like really horrific what happened and
that being said like for me I don't I
don't I don't like the idea of singling
out any group that's been genocided I
mean the Armenian Genocide you have the
holiday more you know so I understand if
people are concerned about old tropes
that were used to justify things like
genocide I get it you know also in the
chat people are saying that Ben Shapiro
did address that specific concern I had
I haven't seen it uh if you could send
it to me please do on my Twitter Luke we
are changing yeah I would love to see it
I'm pretty sure he was pissed off I'm
pretty sure he was like I mean but you
look
like I I I need to watch I watched it
but I it wasn't like the center of my
attention yeah I had playing on Twitter
but I could only imagine if you're
someone like Ben Shapiro and you took a
political stance only later we found out
they took advantage of you like he's
probably gonna be pissed he does not
like to be wrong well he's Mr facts guy
he got that one completely he got that
one completely wrong and if he he came
out and actually corrected himself you
know my apologies I want to see it first
all right
slick Solomon says Tim the average
amount of hands per person is less than
two that's right because the maximum
typically is two and some people don't
have to so that means the average will
be lower
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim a man of
all people arms or no arms I mean yeah
people you know if you only got one or
no arms you'll need a shirt right why
would you have just empty sleeves
do we we live in a world for only the
armful come on
Jacob wertheimer long time chatter first
time listener really Tim and crude
thanks for all the red pills in 2020
while I was confined to my parents
basement you inspired me to be kicked
out life has never been better I'm
engaged please have what if all history
on it would be epic uh I think we will
yeah you know hopefully soon I don't
know I don't know do you know where he's
based out of
um I think he's been living all over the
world recently he's been talking about
he's been living in a bunch of different
countries he did a couple programs on
that but he did his video on who would
win a civil war it's like a million
views yeah and it was recommended to me
and I it was really good I disagree on
his assessment though he makes a bunch
of good points as to why he thinks the
right would win but I think there's just
too much missing from like we did no
single person knows enough about how
loyalties break down or or or not yeah
it could be a situation where the entire
system is eradicated in something
completely foreign erupts like it
doesn't have to be a versus B and one of
those will emerge you know there could
be a major geographical shift in the
next four years which definitely only
changes Coastal and and Rural we're
already seeing it yeah exactly just like
all the people that are in the chat you
remember that the California's moving to
Texas are not all blue a lot of them are
red they're trying to move where they're
more akin to the people that are around
who they live and what did what did
hocals say get out yeah the Republicans
So eventually you might see states where
you're like they would never secede it's
like well all the Republicans left it's
nothing but Democrats they'll vote
they'll say goodbye they'll try and join
Canada or whatever who knows yeah
Mr Thao says Ian Pryor is just Ian
Crossland from the past get it Ian Pryor
that's right that's right
thank you talks with Candace
try to close my PayPal account kept
getting speeches to keep it open finally
they uh they try to close it but kept
finding issues I have to wait 48 hours
for an email before they can close the
account I call BS
I agree Sam nooney says if possible it
would be great to have Tudor Dixon on we
have to get rid of Whitmer who sent five
5600 seniors to their death among so
many other terrible things
yeah that'd be great I'm down you know I
talked about that yesterday I was like
we got to get you know but we're so
close to the election I'll just say this
if uh
you know if who we need to have on we
need to have on uh probably bolduck I'd
imagine that'd be interesting
conversation because you know why New
Hampshire is going Democrat in the
Senate is is strange and uh uh tutor
Dixon would be fantastic we had
mastriano on Kerry Lake's been on
several times I think Carrie Lake will
one day be president uh or at the very
least if she wanted to run she has that
a factor you know X Factor a-lister or
whatever you want to call it
best tier minimum VP
I've I've Democrat friends saying that
and they're they like her yeah
you know when Luke says VP I'm like I
don't know she's president presidential
I say minimum minimally that position I
I disagree
like and what I mean by that is like you
look at VPS you know and it's like
but you look at Carrie like and it's
like yo she could be president I don't
agree with some of her positions but
she's on it she is absolutely smart and
Brilliant when it comes to her
addressing the media yeah you just
called a politician brilliant
well it's not saying much compared to
the other politicians to be honest with
you so let's do let's be real they do
fail in many elements but PR wise she's
brilliant is there any upside to VP
right I mean best case scenario you're
just kind of sitting there waiting worst
case scenario you're you know Kamala
doing the Billy Madison speech
everywhere you know oh man I think I
would like that that would fit my
personality really well because no one
would want me to be president well maybe
they would but people would be like do
not get make sure that President
succeeds because we do not want crazy
Crossing coming in
says Elon personally delivered a message
to Twitter Friday he will clean house
including the kitchen sink what if he
live streams it Elon please live stream
it and he like he can't for legal
reasons but if you know he just walks in
he's like I'm here I'm in Twitter HQ I I
now I own it I'm taking it private and I
have this list of names I'm going to
read them off one at a time it's it's 5
000 employees and I'm gonna read every
name uh John Smith you're fired Janet
doe you're fired that would I would I
would watch the whole thing I would I
would actually do like a reaction live
stream just sitting there being like
eating a bowl of cereal
yeah he wouldn't do it because
um you know legal reasons reading out
people's names whatever but he could do
it on Twitter I guess because he can't
get banned from his own place think
about the crazy things he's gonna tweet
when he's like he's gonna he's gonna
tweet something really like silly and
gross and be like but I own Twitter so
No One's Gonna ban me there's gonna be a
period of creative genius that's going
to be embarked on if everything goes as
planned with Twitter Twitter songs yeah
Twitter songs there you go Twitter or
something you said it yeah something
like that how long do you think it's
going to take for Elon to to just change
the system
like look look all the all the
moderators are still doing their jobs
Elon buying it
like is he gonna put out a memo being
like hey if you're a trust and safety
person no longer banned for these
reasons like how does that work the
monitors will be fired 75 of the company
is going to be laid off most of those
people are just complaining about people
and and then downranking their accounts
or Banning accounts I want you to
imagine
it's Friday night
you know we're wrapping up the show and
we're like oh it's been been fun you
know we're gonna go grab a drink and
hang out and then as you're turning off
the timcast IRL show
you say all right well you know let's
see if anybody wants to go out and grab
a drink maybe your central time and then
all of a sudden your phone goes and you
go anymore and you look at your screen
as a notification and it says tweet by
Alex Jones I'm back baby
and then you're gonna open it up
and it's going to be him in a video
going
to put her shirt off just ripping his
shirt off screaming I'm back I'm
thinking I could see it come on Elon you
have to do it twitio if you can you know
you brand video for Twitter is twittio
and uh they used to have Periscope they
obliterated a periscope which is fine
Stupid Vine was huge yes now now Tick
Tock took over how stupid was that yeah
dumb dumb decision fine got bought I
think they sold out and then got shut
down uh Twitter bought fine then shut it
down that's right that's so stupid
idiotics dumb asses like seriously he
could bring all of that back yeah he
probably will videos you have to compete
yeah so there was a report Twitter is
struggling to keep its power users
they're slowly dwindling
and I think Elon knows this
well here's what I think happened when
Twitter bans you know Alex Jones or Milo
it's making themselves irrelevant I said
this years ago you ban the most
obnoxious people what's the point of
being on the platform
so they start losing users now they have
a disproportionate leftist base the left
now with leverage start saying you
better ban more people and they're like
but we need our super users like well
we'll quit and they're like well
there's more leftists now and we don't
want to lose them so just ban the
conservative guy and it's just a
downward spiral Elon Musk comes in
brings back Alex Jones brings back
Donald Trump yo Donald Trump would make
people go back on Twitter they'd make
more money hands down yeah I don't think
Trump would come back on though I don't
know if he'd want to but he has to the
corporate media would secretly love it
but publicly hate it they were like yes
finally he's back I have a life all the
reply guys are gonna be so happy oh yeah
but they're gonna pretend that they're
not it's a good incentive to Federate uh
truth social and Twitter and and gab and
parlor and mines
when I was working in the Department of
Justice in in 17 and 18. anytime Trump
tweeted reporters were in the same
building as us right so they were down
the hall anytime Trump tweeted something
about anything they all come running
down the hall do you have a comment on
Trump's tweet do you have a comment on
Trump's tweet it was like the one thing
that would just get them running down
the office like no comment no comment no
comment just it was like crack for them
yeah
ready to rumble says did you just say
Carey lake is scum never no Gary likes
amazing we've had on the show a couple
times and I'll tell you exactly why I
say this aside from the videos which are
awesome when she smacks the media down
with their with their BS and their lies
uh we've had a lot of politicians on
this show and you know whenever I get
like a message like oh you know this
politician wants to come come on or that
politician I'm like oh here we go
politicians I know how politicians talk
I know they act we've had a handful of
people we've had like Thomas Massey
Marjorie Taylor green Kerry Lake
they are the opposite of politicians
they come in and they sit and talk to
you like they're anybody else Kerry lake
is especially good because she's
quick-witted she's smart she knows her
stuff and so it's just like having a
real conversation with someone who who
you know it you feel is genuine and we
asked her some complicated off the cuff
questions that like I didn't even have
prepared yeah DMT Criminal Justice
Reform uh you know War on Drugs a lot of
different stuff we got into that I
thought was important that that wasn't
scripted and I appreciate that yeah I
think it's because Carrie Lake actually
has thought about these problems and
these ideas actually wants to fix them
and has real opinions on them and a lot
of politicians will will him and Han
give you a political answer because they
don't know they don't care they just
want to get elected well I I think the
biggest difference was that she was also
willing to say I don't know right very
few politicians do that they give you a
bull crap answer and they just talk
around the question and and give out
generalities she wasn't afraid to say I
don't know I don't know what DMT is you
know what is it tell me what it is
up Carrie Cosmic surgeon says Tim is
obviously not a we are change subscriber
who isn't Tim apparently yeah why aren't
you are you
did we answer the question Senator we we
I I I we are change you know it's a
great question yeah and I think I think
we our change is it's an excellent show
and you know more people should consider
being members to we are changed so I
appreciate your time and your question
and I would I would just ask my opponent
here uh Ian why haven't you advocated
more for people to sign up as Tim guest
I always tip cast members no the topic
right now the discussion is we are
change members of the mind of answer the
question we changed
oh it's no it's present tense
your honor
let's keep it moving if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you it
will be live around 10 50 11 p.m is
usually when it goes up you don't want
to miss it it'll be good fun there's
some big stories we'll talk about you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me at timcast Ian do you want
to shout anything out yeah a couple of
things uh fight for schools my pack in
Virginia uh we're you know we're
fighting the woke school boards there
um also America First legal is where
it's my day job aflegal.org you know all
these things we talk about right the you
know enforcing people's rights Second
Amendment First Amendment you know going
after these woke school systems for
infringing on the rights of parents we
do it all I mean we're we're bringing
cases on behalf of parents on behalf of
um you know individuals in the country
to exercise their rights so you know to
the extent you're dealing with that you
know reach out to us and uh we'll do a
weekend to help you're at the the doj
yeah I got so many questions all right
on the show but anyway if you're a
little bit plump and looking for some
motivation I can't recommend enough you
check out Luke uncensor.com especially
the video I did today talking about the
hero's journey and the possibilities and
the mental mind frame that you could put
yourself in that I think could
potentially benefit you if it doesn't
let me know email me lucanser.com that's
the website and I want to point people
Ian at your Twitter it's end Pryor they
can find there they can find Pfeiffer
schools in America First legal if they
want to go through to those channels
from there it's great to see you man
thank you for the conversation thanks
for having me a history like that it's
really cool catch you later hey I'm Ian
Crossland I love you I'll see you later
and I'm surge.com you guys can find me
in the chat I'll be answering all the
comments later
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out cheers